So, moin leute, heute ist nicht so früh, aber irgendwie bin ich trotzdem noch ein bisschen
müde.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass wir gestern bis 23.15 Uhr oder so Streamstalls
gemacht haben.
Das kann ich jetzt in meinem Alter nicht mehr machen, hier, schon spät, Bettke, zu spät,
Bettke, gleich spüht, am anderen Tag.
Mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwelche komischen Mails wieder gekriegt habe.
Von China-Chinesen-Shops, da sind ja immer lustige Sachen dabei.
Die wollten wieder Zeug von mir.
Hab ich euch das mit dem Telefon gezeigt?
Das hab ich auf Twitter gepostet mit dem Telefon, ja, ja, richtig, ich absolut, Leading-Edge-Telefon
sollte ich testen für den China-Shop.
Fünf Telefon, was aussah, wie 1990.
Hier ist aber anscheinend nichts dabei.
Ah, doch, hier.
Chilling Wang hat geschrieben, alles klar, I'm so lucky to find your YouTube-Channel,
alles klar.
Der Text ist wieder super, wir, Alter, ich weiß gar nicht, was die von mir wollen, lul.
Das kann ich nicht zeigen, ohne Werbung für die zu machen.
Okay, nice.
Dann ist das letzte Video zu Ende und Tag ist der Maxon, ja, immer sonntags um die Zeit.
Ich bin eigentlich sonntags immer so neun bis zehn in dem Dreh bin ich on und dann
bis so, also von neun bis zehn und dann so ungefähr bis, keine Ahnung, 13 Uhr oder
so.
Mal gucken.
So, okay, auf geht's, übrigens, ich hab, sag mal, ist noch mal jemand die Emojis kaputt
im Titel?
Machst du auch Ausblitzungsplätze short, was, was genau, hä, sind bei euch auch die Emojis
in meinem Titel vom Stream kaputt?
Ich glaub, das ist seit der letzten Chrome-Version, guck mal, seit der letzten Chrome-Version
sind die Emojis hier nur noch in schwarz-weiß und im Firefox wird sicherweise, ich weiß
nicht, das liegt, glaub ich, an der letzten Chrome-Version, im Firefox gehen die alle.
Glaube, das ist, das ist kaputt, das ist ja Chromium und Chromium ist auch kaputt.
Werbung für Ausbildungsplätze, na ja, Werbung, Werbung mach ich nur, wenn ich dafür bezahlt
werde oder wenn ich was super geil finde selbst, wenn es was lustiges ist zu zeigen, klar,
warum nicht, aber warum sind die Emojis so kaputt?
Aktuellster Chrome auf Linux gehen die Emojis, ok, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren,
sag bloß, sag bloß, der Windows-Chrome ist kaputt, also muss ich jetzt mal kurz überprüfen.
In Edge gehen sie auch, ok, das ist merkwürdig, wenn die in Edge gehen, weil, Alter, nervt
mich rum, weil das ist ja eigentlich auch Chromium, nee, guck, da sind sie auch kaputt,
wer auch immer hier gebaitet, wer auch immer das wieder erzählt hat.
Chrome sind die auch kaputt, sehr Chromium-based, so, und was unter Linux geht es angeblich,
das werden wir jetzt mal schnell ausprobieren, ob das unter Linux wirklich funktioniert.
Ach du suchst Azubis, ja nee, dann kannst du mal den Link zu der Stellenanzeige schicken,
da kann ich dir im Stream zeigen oder wir können die uns angucken oder so, ja, das war was
ganzes, ich dachte, ich wusste bloß nicht, was da Sache ist, hallo, ich hoffe, ihr habt
nichts gehört, übel sneezen, so, geht es unter Linux, unter Linux, achso, Moment, das ist
FireFox, das ist FireFox, schauen wir mal hier, Chromium, Chromium lege ich schon mal
gar nicht richtig, hatte ich gedacht, nee, kein Bock, okay, ja, hier unter Linux funktionieren
die Emojis, das verstehe ich nicht, ist nicht die aktuellste Version oder was, muss ich
jetzt mal kurz abchecken, oh, da hat sich ein bisschen was getan, aiaiai, aiaia, okay,
das dauert jetzt kurz, seit Jahren, es ist schön, dass du wieder hier bist, Pog, ähm,
ich bin ja schon eine Weile auf Twitch und ich bin immer sonntags morgens am Start, wen
interessieren Emojis, Emojis ist mit das wichtigste im Internet.
Also es gibt zwei Sachen, die sind wichtig, Emoji Support und leider eine Sache, die noch
viel zu wenige Seiten bieten, Twitch Emoji Support, also wir könnten auch Emojis komplett
durch Twitch Emoji setzen, das wäre mir lieber, weil zum Beispiel, es gibt für Pog einfach
keinen gescheiten Emoji Ersatz, was verwendet ihr anstatt Pog für einen Emoji, da gibt
es nicht so wirklich gute, die das Pog Feeling so captchern, ja, ja, ich auch, ich poste da
so manchmal schon einfach, also nicht Screenshots, das sind einfach Bilder, der Pog Sticker,
ja, genau, das geht nicht, nee, nee, weißte nicht, ja ich weiß, das ist ähnlich, aber
ich finde das trifft Pog, so den richtigen Pog einfach nicht richtig, das ist eher so
ho, Pog ist so Pog, ich weiß nicht wie ich das mit dem Geräusch nachmache, das ist eher
so ho Pog, ja, man hat es, man hat es, warum ist Pog eigentlich weg, warum die Pog gelöscht,
Pog hatte ich auch mal als E-Mode drinne, Pog, aber ich muss mal kurz die Nase putzen,
okay, ja, richtig, richtig Pog, jetzt habe ich Pog, ich habe Pog wieder aktiviert, jetzt
über FFZ, Battle Witch TV hat es anscheinend gelöscht, Unusual Domain Names Make, das
können wir gucken, aber das wissen wir eigentlich schon, da haben wir uns schon mal drüber schlau
gemacht vor einer Weile, aber wir können uns das ruhig nochmal angucken, vor allem,
die es nicht wissen, das ist echt interessant, Punkt TV Domains und Punkt, das andere habe
ich vergessen, Punkt TV und noch Punkt CO war das, nee Punkt, egal gucken wir uns gleich
an, das ist wirklich interessant das Thema, nee das trifft es auch nicht so richtig, also
ich finde es gibt keinen richtigen Pog Emoji Ersatz, Modge ist auch weg, haben die wirklich
ausgelöscht, ich hatte Modge doch nie drinne, es ist Chebat gewesen wieder hier, ich hatte
ein Modge nie drin, ein Modge, Moin, Error ODE, Pogs Up, oh Mann, ich bin echt noch müde,
was ist denn hier los, ich habe heute auf YouTube die beste Begründung gelesen, aller Zeiten,
warum die Battlefield 2042 Maps so leer sind, passt mal auf, die kann ich euch nicht vorenthalten,
das ist einfach, die ist so Big Brain die Bewertung, da kommt ihr nicht, die Begründung, die ist
so Big Brain, da kommt ihr nicht drauf.
Wo ist das hin, hat das gelöscht, ach hier, guck mal, beste Begründung, du sagst doch
selbst Battlefield 2042 Spiel in einer zerstörten Welt oder ist es doch normal, dass es leere
Plätze gibt, Massive File Fat, Alter, richtig, richtig Big Brain, ich mein man kennt es, man
kennt es, also natürlich haben die die Maps nur so leer gemacht, um die vorhandene Lore
besser zu stützen, aber ich mein man kennt es, man kennt es, zum Beispiel wenn man mal
nach Griechenland geht und dort wo vor 2000, über 2000 Jahren irgendwelche größeren
Sachen standen, die sind auch alle weg, die sind einfach despawned, es gibt keine antiken
griechischen und römischen und sowas auch immer Sachen mehr, alles despawned, alles
weg, das da drunter, ach hier, das hab ich gar nicht gelesen, ich hab nur das gelesen,
es ist das beste Game seit langem, ich fahre es so hart, es ist einfach geil, hier, da gibt
es ein paar Dinge nur, ja gut, jeder wasser, jeder wie er will, ja also, also wenn es Spaß
macht ist ja in Ordnung, ich hab da keine Schmerzen mit, hättest du immer noch vom Battlefield
ja, ich würd das noch nicht kaufen, ja ich würd das nicht kaufen, das Wort darf man
nicht mehr verwenden auf Twitch, ach guck mal wir haben Link zu meinem PC, das find
ich ja tatsächlich mal spannend, wusste ich gar nicht, dass wir sowas haben, ist das
denn, ja das ist noch aktuell, das ist noch aktuell, einzige was dazu gekommen ist, ist
einmal 16G RAM zusätzlich, der Rest ist aktuell, ist schon krass oder, PC von Ende 2000, der
PC ist jetzt genau 4 Jahre alt, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen oder, 4 Jahre alter PC
immer noch top aktuell, da sagt der Boomer in mir, das hätt es früher nicht gegeben,
ich hab einen Pang, danke schon 13 Monate Subscription, jetzt hast du auch hier den,
nee der hat das letzte Monat schon den Gold Keks mit Kette, es wird mal Zeit für noch
mehr Badges würde ich sagen, wisst ihr das die Badges, die ich jetzt in Twitch reingehauen
hab, dass die Badges eigentlich, dass ich die eigentlich machen lassen habe für YouTube,
dass ich dort Channel Membership einschalten kann, easy money, das muss ich vor Weihnachten
machen, vor Weihnachten sind die dort immer spendabel, LeChuck 1978, danke für den Sub,
Sellouts ja muss sein, danach brauch ich noch einen Patreon und noch einen OnlyFans und
noch einen, was gibt es sonst noch so, keine Ahnung, nee Quatsch, also ich glaube im Vergleich
zu anderen, etwas größeren Channels, ist mein Sellout doch verhältnismäßig gering,
und dass ich EA, dass ich Battlefield Sellout Videos mache, also Battlefield, denen danke
für 7 Monate Subscription, dass ich den, dass ich diese EA Sponsoring Geschichte mach, da
hab ich zugestimmt bevor ich wusste wie kacke das Game ist, was soll ich machen, ich muss
ja noch eins machen, also ein Hazard Zone Video muss ich machen, das müssen wir heute
aufnehmen Leute, also Cap'n Poggers, wenn du Bock hast, braucht da noch 2 andere Leute
nachher gucken, vielleicht hab ich auch jemand schon, da müssen wir Hazard Zone spielen,
aber nicht Onstream, Hazard Zone, da mach ich ein Video, 7-8 Minuten, mach das ganz
neutral und sachlich, ohne es übermäßig zu halten noch zu flammen, lade das hoch,
am Montag oder so, ach naja guckt ihr mal das letzte Sponsored Video an, da hatten schon
einige was dagegen, ich kann das verstehen, es ist jetzt aber auch nicht so, dass mich
das großartig schockt, aber ich hätte normalerweise, ja ich hab, nee ich bin nicht erkältet, aber
ich weiß auch nicht, ich bin irgendwie grad bisschen, irgendwie läuft meine Nase bisschen,
keine Ahnung warum, ich hab, eigentlich hab ich gar nichts, zu lang wach gewesen gestern,
unser guter Kacke-W-Freund hat auch was zu Battlefield 2, ich soll viel zu sagen, ok,
das muss man uns angucken, Sekunde, das ist immer das beste, Moment, Moment, Moment,
das muss man uns angucken, lange keine Risitas Geschichte mehr hier gesehen, Junkler, Junkler,
ok, ist das vielleicht auch auf YouTube erhältlich, nee das ist nur hier, nur hier angehängt,
Klassische, Klassische, Klassische Crap Auflösung, Chat aus, stimmt, sonst sieht man nix, ne,
Chat aus und Chico ausblenden, ich war es gleich neu, ich muss mal lauter machen, Junkler,
Junkler, ok, jetzt, jetzt Fullscreen, bam, so ist es,
ja, es ist halt einfach, es ist halt einfach, was war das, vier, Moment, vier, vier, ok,
Breakthrough, Conquest, Portal und Hazard Soul vielleicht,
das stimmt, das stimmt, ja,
ja, gab es ja nicht,
und als letztes, als das Leben von Regeln ausging, waren wir alle schreitend
und er hat mich gegründet
und ich war nicht mehr da, ich war immer noch mit den Schreien
bis heute
ich habe mir gar nicht mehr aufgefallen
das war mir so klar, instant
naja
ja, so wird es kommen, so wird es kommen
das muss eigentlich fertig sein
ja, das stimmt
ja, schon was wahres dran
aber mittlerweile kann man das ja gar nicht anders ertragen, als sich drüber lustig machen
ist nicht, geht ja nicht
ja, Day 1 Patch gab es ja im Prinzip gar nicht
es gab so einen Mini-Patch, der so kleine, kleinste Sachen gefixt hat
ohne irgendwie spürbar zu sein, wirklich
ach ja, Leute
also, ich muss heute wie gesagt ein bisschen Hazard Zone Gameplay aufnehmen
dass ich da morgen ein Video draus wurschen kann
vielleicht mache ich heute Abend wieder ein bisschen Stream
also, ich werde das Game jetzt noch ein bisschen spielen
dass ich zumindest ein bisschen Value raus bekomme
für meine, was kosten die Gold Edition
70 Euro oder so
warum ist es so schwer als Infanterist viele Kills zu machen
ich schaffe oft nur 10 per Runde und werde ständig von Fahrzeugen killen
das ist ganz einfach, ich zeige dir mal was von gestern aus dem Stream, was du machen musst
Hoblords
du musst das machen wie ich gestern im Stream
du brauchst die richtige Kombination
aus Waffe und Noob Gegnern
dann geht das, guck hier
Hä?
warum hat er, Moment
ich hab Scatter, also ich hab Scatter gesagt, so wie Hanzo das sagt
warum hat es, hat Twitch, hat Twitch da Beleidigung erkannt und gemutet oder was ist in meinem
Moment, Moment, Moment, was?
oder hat mein Mikrofon geklippt
Moment, Moment
nice, ich muss weg, da sind total viele hier
oh, fuck
guckt euch den Killstreak an
ja, das ist gemuted
habt ihr gestern, hat sich das für euch im Stream genauso angehört
abgehackt
ich hab gesagt Scatter, also
so wie Hanzo das sagt
ist das gemuted jetzt nachhinein?
haben die gedacht, ich bin voll am Fluver, Scatter ist ja sowas wie Scheiße glaube ich auch
die haben das nachgedrückt, ich fasse es nicht
falls irgendjemand Overwatch gespielt hat
guckt euch den Killstreak, jetzt, jetzt hat man es gehört
Hanzo, Hanzo
ich dreh voll ab in dem, guckt euch den Killstreak, du musst also, für den Killstreak du brauchst
kack Gegner, die spielen wie Bots
und du musst Pepega29 spielen
dann ist alles gut
da sind so viele Hanzo-Mains da
Hanzo-Mains, any Hanzo-Mains
war ja schon spät, genau
alter, die wurden gerekt
Pepega29 ist leer
guckt euch mal an, wie sie es nicht checken, man
kann es sein, dass mich das nicht auf der Map gerendert hat oder so?
sind das Bots?
spiele ich gegen Bots?
guckt euch das an
das ist doch nicht normal
gleich Nuke, Leute, gleich Nuke
die Moab
da ist sie
Boris, Boris, lass mich in Ruhe
Boris
da ist die Moab
da ist die Moab, Leute
hörst du das mal an?
die sehen mich nicht, oder?
oder doch?
nee, das ist langer Lauf, das ist kein Schalldämpfer, nee, nee
ich hab keinen Heal, das ist mein Problem
also das muss man
das muss man machen für nice Killstreaks
einfach 20 Kills
in Battlefield 2020
man braucht kacke Gegner
und man muss Pepega29 spielen
dann ist alles gut
nice hacks, lul
der hat wirklich mal ein Kram rausgeschnitten aus dem Stream
wir testen das jetzt mal
ich spreche das jetzt genauso aus wie gestern
und ihr müsst mir mal sagen
wobei, ich kann mir ja selbst
Moment, ich kann mir ja selbst zuhören
ich kann mir ja selbst zuhören
das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert
und dann gucken wir nachher im Watt
ob das gemutet ist
so, gucken wir mal hier
also, ich hab irgendwie sowas gesagt
in der Richtung wie
Hanzo mains, any Hanzo mains
Scatter, Scatter
nein!
wir gucken nachher im Watt, Leute
Scatter
wir gucken nachher im Watt
ob das gemutet wird
also wenn das
wenn die Schimpfwörter muten
in Watt
dann wirds ja schon echt grenzwertig langsam
außerdem war das kein Schimpfwort
das hat sich halt angefangen wie eins
Chat wieder einplatten, ja
ne, es wird nicht live gefiltert
es wird ja im Watt anscheinend gefiltert
also da bin ich mal echt gespannt nachher
wo ist Chico?
muss wieder eingeplantet werden
pp29
das ist was, das ist wieder Metawaffe
das ist sowas von die Metawaffe
geht ja gar nicht
oh man
also, machen wir mal YouTube Refresh
gibt es noch ein paar spannende Sachen
die man sich angucken kann
Halo Infinite Showcase
ja muss ich immer noch
ich hab's schon installiert seit ein paar Tagen
aber ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen
bin kein riesiger Halo Fan
aber das soll diesmal richtig gut sein
hast du privat noch Kontakt zu DrKaboom?
das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her gewesen
wo wir was voneinander gehört haben
kennst du den Clip?
ne
Christian
what the fuck
ich hab'n Godmode freigeschaltet oder was
das ist genau das gleiche, man sieht ihn einfach nicht, oder?
was zur Hölle, Alter
guck's dir an, Alter, ich maschine einfach durch
ne Moment, das ist noch ein bisschen schlimmer als was ich auf Breakaway hatte
die sehen ihn gar nicht, oder?
jetzt wird's wild, Freunde, jetzt wird's richtig wild
die sehen ihn nicht, oder?
gut, wild, okay, hey, das ist live-test hier, ja
das ist ein absoluter live-test
oh man, sie sieht mich mit der Brille?
na, sie hat mich nicht
liebenlos, er ist dead, glaub ich
die sehen ihn nicht
Gottes Willen
einfach stärkste Runde EU West jetzt
BTF, Alter, das Spiel ist so kaputt, man
warum sind die Leute unsichtbar?
es geht anscheinend
das liegt nicht an den Gegnern, die Gegner sehen ihn einfach nicht
ich frag mich, wie das bei den Gegnern aussieht, wenn man stirbt
ob die dann irgendwas angezeigt bekommen, oder so
was? Hau in Holland
aha, haue, haue, was ist das für ein Salz, haue
da gab's ein bisschen Knoppe, oder?
ich glaube,51
Dass jemand mit so nem Bild kein echter Hacker ist, das sind wir uns glaub ich einig.
Ja dann gucken wir uns das an.
Das ist wirklich ein sehr interessantes Thema mit Punkt TV Domains.
Ich kenne das schon, also das Video nicht, aber für die die es noch nicht kennen, ich
glaube das ist wirklich, das sollte jeder mal gehört haben.
Ehm, Emoji Domains, nö Emoji Domains, was heißt Band, es gibt sogar ein extra Standard
mittlerweile für Emoji Domains, egal, oder für Sonder, sag mal für Sonderzeichen, das
sind nicht Emoji Domains, für Sonderzeichen in Domains und dazu gehören ja Emojis dazu.
Also wer immer dachte, dass Punkt TV was mit TV zu tun hatte, stimmt nicht.
Also Punkt TV ist die Top Level Domain von diesen kleinen Inselstaaten.
Guck mal hier, DE, habt ihr gesehen, DE hat richtig viel, habt ihr hier, guck mal, DE ist
richtig big, ja US benutzt kaum einer, das ist lustig, US Domains gibt es sehr selten,
es benutzen eigentlich alle internationale immer nur KOM, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja.
Tokelau. Ich denke, viele Leute, die das sehen, haben noch nie von Tokelau gehört.
Wie ist diese kleine Insel das größte Ort auf der Internet? Was ist hier los?
Um das zu verstehen, müssen wir uns an diese Tafel anschauen.
Das sind die Top-Level-Domäne des Landeskodes.
In jedem Land der Welt gibt es zwei Charakter-Domäne.
Man denkt, Punkt TV hat etwas mit Fernsehen zu tun, hat es aber nicht.
Da ist bestimmt schön, da ist bestimmt, da ist bestimmt sehr nice auf Tuvalu.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das heißt sie gibt es bald nicht mehr, oder wie?
Nochmal eins einzuwerfen, es gibt auch, es gibt auch eine Domain,
eine Top Level Domain, Punkt Services, was meint ihr, wem diese Domain gehört?
Also kann man gerade nicht auflösen, aber die Domain gibt es.
Ja, die gehört mir, aber nicht ursprünglich, die hat sich ein Mod, die hat sich der Serious
Max gesichert und die haben wir dann übertragen, also ohne den hätten wir die Domain nicht,
aber jetzt, jetzt, CACWay Services haben wir am Start.
Wenn das das Highlight war, dass da irgendein Stein steht, ist glaube ich nicht so viel
los dort.
Wie viel kostet die Domain, ich glaube irgendwie 8 Euro im Jahr oder so.
Nee, ich habe noch Heilo nicht ausgebildet, aber Teilo können wir machen, das ist eine
richtig gute Idee.
Lange für den Zap, Leute, wollen wir uns, wir holen uns unsere Emoji Domain gleich nach
dem Stream.
Bam.
Ich hätte aber lieber Twitch Emojis in der Domain.
Ich clique damit an drauf undvocate.
Ich mache es nem Emoje oder challenging.
Die Art, wie es funktioniert, ist, dass das Emoji in etwas transkodiert wird, das einen Punicode genannt wird,
welches eine Charakterrepräsentation des Symbols ist.
Also, dieses Domain wird dies.
Du musst dir einen Emoji-Domain ausprobieren.
Ich war zu müde, das Land und die Bühne zu machen, während ich dort war, und habe ihn in Australien zurückgebracht.
Es gibt viele Rezellers, von denen man diese online kaufen kann.
Australien, oi.
Wähle deinen Lieblings-Emoji.
Oi, Kumpel.
Jetzt hast du ein Gefühl für das, was in der Pazifik passiert.
Das bringt uns zurück zu diesem Map und zu Tokalau.
Die kleine Nation in der Pazifik.
Das ist eine Territorie von New Zealand und ist zu rund 1.500 Menschen heim.
Doch so viele.
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist auch wirklich was, wo man, also, die das auch machen können.
Ich meine, bei denen, die haben wahrscheinlich richtig geilen Sonnenstand, also vom Winkel her,
dass sie wenig Flasche brauchen für Solar-Panels.
Die haben wahrscheinlich sehr viel Sonnenschein im Jahr.
Und die haben wahrscheinlich Land zu Einwohner gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also, ich glaube, für die ist das top.
Die können einfach komplett, komplett Solar-Energie machen.
Aber dann sieht man mal, wo das funktioniert, und da kann man sich fragen,
ist es bei uns realistisch, komplett Solar-Energie zu machen?
Dann wird man wahrscheinlich zu dem Schluss kommen.
Nee, da brauchst du andere Sachen.
Und die haben auch nicht viel, es kommt ja auch noch dabei,
die haben ja auch nicht viel, was wahnsinnig viel Strom zieht.
Außer die ganzen Bitcoin-Miners gehen da jetzt hin.
Ich hatte auch mal eine TK-Domain.
Mir fällt gerade ein, ich hatte auch mal eine TK-Domain.
Das ist schon 25 Jahre her.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass ich Mist erzähle.
Aber ich bilde mir ein, das war eine TK-Domain.
Für meinen CS-Klan damals, oder für unseren CS-Klan, hatten wir den Punkt TK-Domain.
Ja, damals gab es sowas noch.
Wir werden gleich hier nach dem Stream geben, es gibt das Emoji-Domain.
Ich meine, wir haben CACW.Services, dann brauchen wir jetzt noch
irgendwas in der Richtung mit Emojis.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Coden und Programmieren als OOMG.
Will ich das mir wirklich...
Was verdient ein IT-Projektleiter?
Ohje, IT-Projektleiter auch noch bei einem Amt.
Also sprich bei irgendwelchen Behörden.
Das ist ja richtig MonkaS.
Das ist ein gutes Video.
Okay, gucken wir uns dann gleich.
Schauen wir uns gleich an.
Aber das in Kombination ist bestimmt richtig MonkaS.
Mal gucken.
Also ich wäre überrascht, wenn er wirklich gut verdient.
Also alles, was ich bisher gesehen habe, bei Stellenangeboten, wo dieses...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Diese Abkürzung für diesen öffentlichen Tarif-Blah-Kram.
Also dort, wo Trinscher, sie werden nach Entgeltgruppe XY bezahlt nach TVÖBLUB.
Sonst war es ja TVÖD.
Das war alles immer...
Ja, also man kann dafür schon arbeiten und man kann dafür auch überleben.
Aber wirklich üppig und gut ist es nicht.
Was?
TVLE12.
Guck mal, was das ist.
Das ist eigentlich nicht viel.
Ja, gucken wir mal.
E12.
Man bekommt mal 12.
Gut, 6 wird kaum.
Nehmen wir mal die Mitte hier.
4000, 4500 mal 12.
Das ist jetzt...
Das ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Das ist sicherlich nicht hier der große Wurf.
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie du da Steuern bezahlen musst.
Wenn du weniger Steuern bezahlen musst, kann es natürlich trotzdem richtig nice sein.
Netto bleiben.
Naja, so krass ist es jetzt nicht für eine Projektleiterposition.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist Tarifstufe 3.
Dafür muss man ja irgendwie, glaube ich, 6 Jahre oder so da sein.
Wobei, nee, Moment, das stimmt nicht.
Für Stufe 4 musst du, glaube ich, 6 Jahre da sein.
Du musst ein Jahr für Stufe 1, also du startest mit Stufe 1.
Dann musst du ein Jahr dabei sein für Stufe 2.
Dann musst du 2 Jahre dabei sein für Stufe 3.
Dann musst du 2 Jahre dabei sein, also quasi 4 Jahre für Stufe 3, oder?
Hab ich das jetzt richtig gerechnet?
Ein Jahr, 2 Jahre, 4 Jahre.
Das ist doch so komisch gemacht irgendwie, wenn man da aufsteigt.
Also musst wahrscheinlich erstmal 4 Jahre dabei sein.
Ab 4. Jahr Stufe 3, ja, ok, dann stimmt das.
Also der Wahnsinn ist es nicht.
Und wahnsinnig viel, also du musst im Prinzip ähnlich Steuern bezahlen wie überall anders auch.
Ach, er ist Beamte, er ist A12.
Wo steht das jetzt hier drinnen?
A12?
Beamtebund.
Besoldungsgruppe A12.
Da kann man dann schon mal durchaus sagen, das ist in Ordnung.
Wobei, Moment, das ist ja mal 12, das ist ja mal 12.
Sekunde, das ist ja mal 12.
Müssen wir erstmal rechnen.
Äh, nee, Moment.
Brutto?
Ich check's nicht.
Ok, das ist nicht so gut.
Aber...
Das hier ist glaube ich ganz ok.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, ich müsste es ja so ausrechnen.
Das sind aber eine ganze Ecke weniger Steuern.
Das ist durchaus in Ordnung dann.
Ja.
Also das hier sieht erstmal nicht viel aus.
Aber das hier ist dann nicht schlecht, weil es sind bloß 22% Steuern.
Ja, da kann man sich da eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Das ist dann durchaus in Ordnung.
Ich meine, da müsst ihr woanders 20% mehr verdienen, dass ihr auf das kommt.
Also das kann durchaus attraktiv sein, denke ich mal.
So, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also.
Coden und Programmieren als Beamter.
Zeig mal her.
Tossmusik.
Was machen die da?
Was ist das?
J-Unit.
Ist das Java?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja.
Na gut.
Ich habe eigentlich gar nicht so viel, um Java zu flamen.
Java ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Ach so, ich.
Ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal nachdenken.
Ich weiß, dass manche in der Privatwirtschaft IT-Projekt leider mehr verdienen.
Aber mir macht meine Arbeit Spaß.
Oh, das klippt aber ziemlich.
Und das ist auch für eine gute Sache.
Hallo.
Alter, die Musik.
Ken Quaid.
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt und arbeite als IT-Projektleiter beim Landesamt für Statistik in Fürth.
Ich fahre gerne mit dem Fahrrad und das tut mir auch gut.
Also von der Bewegung her habe ich es nötig.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Wie gesagt, das ist auch der Grund, warum ich mich mindestens eine Stunde am Tag mal draußen bewege.
Man könnte es Sport nennen, aber ich nenne es mal eher bewegen.
Weil es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich danach irgendwie 30 Millionen Kalorien verbrannt habe oder so.
Aber das ist schon ein Unterschied von gar nicht bewegen zu 1, 1,5 Stunden, 2 Stunden sich ein bisschen bewegen.
Das ist ein Riesenunterschied, was Rücken angeht, was Nackenkopfweh angeht, Herz, Kreislauf, alles.
Also ein bisschen bewegen ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Ich weiß, es kommt aus meinem Mund, ja, aber.
Alter, was ist denn mit der Musik los?
Bye bye.
Die Musik ist ja richtig.
Grausam, ich hoffe, das ist keine Toss Musik, Alter.
Also da holen wir uns ein Smoothie.
Ich habe auch mal eine Zeit lang Smoothies getrunken.
Ich habe mir sogar so einen Smoothie Maker gekauft und einmal habe ich mir in irgendeinem Geschäft in Frankfurt so ein Rucola based Smoothie geholt.
Und Alter, das war so eklig, seitdem trinke ich keine mehr.
Vielen Dank.
Also ich gehe da als erstes hin, weil danach bricht üblicherweise die Hölle los.
Und dann habe ich sicherlich keine Zeit mehr, den zu holen.
Stell dir vor, du wirst dafür weggestreikt, das glaube ich nicht.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Warum holt man sich einen Rucola Smoothie? Ich wusste das nicht.
Bei uns in der Kantine hatten die immer so Daily wechselnde Dinger und da habe ich mir immer einen geholt, die waren auch alle ganz okay.
Aber dieser Rucola Smoothie war so abartig, dass seitdem trinke ich da gar nichts mehr.
Okay, wo ist er? Um neun?
Ja gut, also für den einen Tag die Woche, wo ich gerade nach Frankfurt fahre, bin ich auch ungefähr um neun da und haue dann früher wieder ab,
weil ich keinen Bock mehr habe, so früh aufzustehen.
Ich telefoniere viel, aber ich nutze auch ein Chatprogramm und teile den Bildschirm.
Richtig, richtig, richtig schön klassisches Telefon.
Wer von wann ist denn das Video?
Wo sind die überhaupt vor Ort?
Also bei mir ist, ich glaube ich habe für die Arbeit mit so einem richtigen Telefon jetzt zwei Jahre nicht mehr telefoniert.
Alles nur per Headset und Teams.
So arbeite ich mit den Kollegen zusammen.
Als IT-Projektleiter machen wir die Wartung und Weiterentwicklung von Software.
Wenn die ein Problem hat, dann müssen wir das beheben.
D.h. er ist derjenige, der dafür sorgt, dass Projekte eigentlich nicht 30 Jahre dauern und 500% mehr kosten als das, was ursprünglich geplant war.
Sinn stiften, weil ich sehen kann, dass Verwaltungsprozesse besser ablaufen, dadurch, dass die Software zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Ich hoffe, das Daily wird als nächstes.
Ach ja, die sind richtig agil.
Richtig agil.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben auch einen Certified Scrum Master mit dabei, sonst geht das nicht.
Das ist eine kurze Teambesprechung.
Da sagt jeder kurz, was er gemacht hat oder sie und was als nächstes ansteht und ob es irgendwelche Hindernisse gibt.
Schönen guten Morgen.
Hattest du noch Daten drauf?
Ihr könnt selber sagen, eher ja, eher nein.
Bis dahin, tschüss.
Eher ja, eher nein.
So eine Schätzfrage.
Das finde ich auch bei Projektleuten geil.
Wenn du sagst, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie lange das dauert, ich habe mich damit noch nie beschäftigt.
Ja, meinst du, das klappt eher?
Eher ja oder eher nein?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe das noch nie gemacht.
Das ist genau so.
Letztens, genau sowas hatten wir letztens auch.
Ohne Scheiß.
Da ging es darum, ob wir einen Rollback Plan haben für Wartungsarbeit.
Also wurde gefragt in dieser Runde, gibt es einen Rollback Plan für Wartungsarbeiten?
Und da meinte derjenige, naja gut, man könnte die Comets richtig machen und das Config Management nochmal laufen lassen, aber eigentlich ist das kein wirklicher Rollback Plan.
Und da meinte er so, ja, was würdest du jetzt sagen?
Eher ja oder eher nein?
Fuck.
Der wollte einfach nur in seiner Checkliste irgendwas anhaken und wenn er das falsch anhakt, ging der Prozess wahrscheinlich nicht weiter.
Bis später.
Ja, ist mir schon wichtig, dass eine gute Stimmung, eine kollegiale Stimmung im Team herrscht und die Leute Spaß an der Arbeit haben.
Ja, wir könnten jetzt mal rüber gehen zum Alex und eine Runde Pair Programming machen.
Was ist er denn jetzt eigentlich genau?
Ist er jetzt Teamleiter?
Ist er jetzt Projektleiter?
Ist er jetzt Programmierer?
Ist er jetzt irgendwie Code Reviewer?
Ist er irgendwie Ticketschubser?
Was ist er denn jetzt eigentlich?
Zusammen an einem Problem und man lernt gegenseitig voneinander und das Wissen streut auch weiter.
Also ich muss mal ganz im Ernst sagen, es hat mit mir noch nie ein Projektleiter Pair Programmed.
Pair Programmed eigentlich außer manchmal ein paar Kollegen, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe, weil ich sag, komm lass uns das zusammen angucken.
Ehe keiner, aber ein Projektleiter schon mal gar nicht.
Ich kenn bei uns noch nicht mal irgendwie einen Projektleiter, der auch nur verstehen würde, was da auf dem Bildschirm großartig passiert.
Okay, mit dem Thema aus.
Hallihallo, wir haben für die Wahlen gesagt bekommen, dass es gut sein kann, dass sich der Algorithmus ändert, mit dem die Sitzeverteilung durchgeführt wird bei der nächsten Landtagswahl.
Ist das so kompliziert?
Bevor wir den Algorithmus tatsächlich in die Software einbauen, wird er in einem abgeschlossenen Testfall geprüft.
Ist das irgendwie so richtig Big Brain? Geht das nur noch mit Machine Learning und Blockchain für die Sitzeverteilung?
Okay, ist aber schon was dran natürlich.
Wenn sich das geändert hat, wie sich das Ganze berechnet wird, dann muss das natürlich geupdatet werden, sonst stimmt es ja nicht.
Ein gutes Gefühl damit haben, dann darf er auch mit rein.
Also sprich einmal Comet Cherrypick.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob es klappt.
Ey, wie ich da keinen Bock hätte, wenn der Typ neben mir stehen würde die ganze Zeit, wenn ich das mache.
Ja, passt noch nicht ganz so.
Okay.
Eklige Tastatur.
Ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal nachdenken.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit auch so Tastaturen, so ähnliche.
Und ich mag so flache Tastaturen einfach nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir mal vor 2, 3 Jahren oder so eine Duckymon Skyline gekauft und habe die mit auf die Arbeit genommen.
Und wisst ihr was das Schlimmste ist?
Oder was ist denn nicht das Schlimmste?
Das Beste ist, das ist ein Fremdgerät.
Und es hat sich trotzdem noch keiner beschwert.
Eigentlich darf ich das gar nicht, weil es ein Fremdgerät ist.
Nee, die habe ich selbst bezahlt.
Kann das sein, dass es hier einfach Quatsch ist?
Ja, also jetzt haben wir eine Nullpointer Exception.
Das heißt, es ist ja nicht der Zuteilungsdiviso Minimum.
Genau, also manchmal passiert ein Flüchtigkeitsfehler.
Man kann natürlich durch Hinschauen auf Anhieb alles richtig machen.
Ja, so wie bei uns, wenn wir irgendwas programmieren im Stream.
Da ist auch nie was falsch.
Der Testfall.
Also ich würde noch mal aufs Knöpfchen drücken.
Dafür braucht ihr also einen Projektleiter.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Jetzt ist der Test grün.
Ein grünes Häkchen.
Und wir wissen ja alle, wenn die Tests grün sind, dann läuft es auch genauso wie gedacht.
Und nachdem man ja eh auf jeden Fall programmiert, das ist ja die logische Schlussfolgerung daraus,
braucht man auch keine Tests.
Und es geht eh immer.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Just, äh, man fällt jetzt nichts Dummes ein.
Einfach keine Fehler machen.
Es macht schon Spaß zu programmieren.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich denke schon, dass ich auch manchmal nerdig wirke.
Das trifft schon zu.
Aber ich würde es nicht so darstellen wollen, dass nur Nerds in ihrer eigenen Welt leben.
Weil jeder Mensch hat halt einfach nur sein Umfeld.
Überhaupt nicht.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, bei uns in der IT ist wirklich alles vertreten an Leuten.
Du hast so Kellerkinder wie mich, die den ganzen Tag nichts anderes machen, wie vom Rechten sitzen.
Du hast, wir haben sogar einen Pilot bei uns.
Also Hobby.
Also Hobbypilot, der in seiner Freizeit Propellerflugzeuge fliegt und sowas.
Also es ist wirklich alles dabei.
Es ist wirklich durch die Bank weg.
Kannst du halt gar nicht mehr sagen, dass das alles nur so Kellerkinder sind wie ich.
Rüdiger, keine Kapriolen.
Als ich in der Schweiz angefangen habe...
Moment, das habe ich jetzt nicht gelesen.
Was?
Bachelor Computation Engineering.
Master Geoinformationssysteme.
Ah, nice.
Auslandsprogramm, Rechenzentrum und IT-Firma.
Arbeit in der Rechenzentrum und IT-Firma.
Da kann ja auch alles sein.
Arbeit in der Schweiz.
Alles klar.
Als ich in der Schweiz angefangen habe, da war das Einstiegsgehalt 85.000 Franken und
höher bin ich nicht mehr gekommen.
Ja, das ist wie viel?
Wie viel sind 85.000 Franken?
Haben sie das jetzt nicht irgendwie in den Euro gebunden?
Das haben die 81.000 Euro gekoppelt jetzt.
Stand da.
Egal.
82 bei...
Ey, wisst ihr was?
Der verdient fast das gleiche wie ich.
Mit einem Tag weniger.
Nee, wie viel...
Warte mal.
Nee, ich habe 58...
Nee, wie viel hat...
Leute, ich habe es doch letztens in dem Video gesagt, wie viel ich verdiene.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen, Mann.
Zack, ich arbeite hier auch nur vier Tage in die Woche.
Muss man vorspulen.
Muss man selbst anhören, was ich gesagt habe.
In fünf Tagen wohlgemerkt.
Hier, da.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das sagen darf, wie das ist.
Also.
Und so.
Wenn man das nimmt und das alles zusammenrechnet, an manchen Stellen rundet man mal ein bisschen
auf und dann rundet man am Ende noch ein bisschen ab.
Dann verdiene ich, auf fünf Tage wohlgemerkt, ungefähr klat 70.000 Euro.
Ja, und jetzt auf vier Tage?
Also 70.000.
So.
In fünf Tagen wohlgemerkt.
In vier Tagen ist das dann mal 0,8 in die 56.000.
Ja, das finde ich ja cool.
Wir arbeiten, also der arbeitet auch nur 80%.
Das heißt, da ist auch nur vier Tage die Woche da.
Wir verdienen ungefähr das Gleiche.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass er wahrscheinlich, wenn er Beamter ist, deutlich weniger Steuern
bezahlen muss und am Ende mehr rausbekommt.
Ich verdiene 4110 Euro brutto.
Ja, okay.
Und 2980 Euro.
Das ist mehr als ich.
Das ist mehr.
Siehst du, der Steuer macht einiges aus.
Das macht einiges aus.
Der Krieger hat mich gerated.
Dankeschön.
Poggers, Leute.
Richtig Poggers.
Jetzt würden wir essen gehen.
Und euch würde gleich auffallen an den Behörden.
Da sagt man immer Mahlzeit.
Das ist auch so ein Spruch, den kann ich nicht ab.
Das sagen die Leute bei uns.
Das sagen die Leute auch bei uns immer so im Mittag.
Mahlzeit, Mahlzeit.
Das ist so ein dummer Spruch.
Und dann, wenn du schon 50 Leute auf dem Gang gesagt hast, Mahlzeit, Mahlzeit.
Dann musst du dann auch, wenn du am Empfang vorbeiläufst, musst du auch noch sagen, Mahlzeit.
Das ist...
Ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen nehme ich mir meistens was mit.
Dann kann ich sitzen bleiben und muss nicht mit anderen Menschen interagieren.
Hi.
Ich hätte gerne ein Burrito, bitte.
Ein Burrito?
Exzellent.
Was hat er da?
Moment, ich muss kurz Essen analysen.
Was haben wir da?
Chips?
Danke.
Chips? Nee, Pommes frites, oder?
Wird doch auch mit Salat.
Guten Appetit.
Jetzt Coding-Übungen mit den Boys.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, es ist echt...
Also mir liegt es fern, das jetzt zu flamen.
Aber sonderlich Projektleiterisch wirkt das auf mich jetzt nicht.
Das wirkt auf mich eher, als ist er so eine Art Teamleiter,
der irgendwie alles auf mich macht.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Art Teamleiter.
Das ist so eine Art Teamleiter.
Der irgendwie alles machen muss.
Also irgendwie eher so eine Richtung Teamleiter,
Senior-Developer, einer für alles, weil wir nicht genug Leute haben.
Wir machen jetzt eine Coding-Cutter.
Und da treffen wir uns im Dojo.
Oh, cringe, hör mir auf, ich hasse diese Begriffe dafür.
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt und dass das relativ beliebt ist,
aber ich finde das so cringe, diese Ausdrücke immer.
Das Dojo ist eine Spielwiese, um das Programmieren zu üben.
Wir haben uns für heute eine Aufgabe rausgesucht.
Also das gibt's. Und ja, das nennt sich auch so.
Aber ich versuche das immer irgendwie zu umschreiben.
Also Challenges oder so, das ist schon durchaus okay.
Aber, oh, Riesenfrage im Chat. Sekunde, das muss ich jetzt erst mal lesen.
Frage, die Mac-Adresse ist doch dafür da,
dass der Router weiß, was für ein Gerät es ist, oder?
Hm...
Äh...
Okay, das ist jetzt schwierig zu sagen.
Also, nee, dafür ist die Mac-Adresse nicht da.
Aber ich weiß, was du meinst.
Du meinst wahrscheinlich den DHCP-Teil in deiner Fritzbox,
der anhand der Mac-Adresse zuordnen kann,
was du für eine IP-Adresse bekommen sollst,
wenn du feste Reservierungen hast.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du das meinst.
Aber dafür ist eigentlich...
Also, so wie du es geschrieben hast, stimmt das nicht. Nee.
Wir haben bei uns in der Schule ein öffentliches Netzwerk,
und wenn man sich damit verbindet, muss man sich,
ah ja, das nennt sich Captive Portal,
muss man sich im Web-Interface einmal verifizieren
mit einem Code und dann niemals mehr.
Also könnte ich doch von den Schuhlaptops die Mac-Adresse nehmen
und die auf meinem Laptop handy change,
dann hätte ich Internet.
Das kommt drauf an, wie das gemacht ist mit der Alternifizierung.
Wenn das irgendwie Mac-Adressen basiert ist, ja,
dann würde das funktionieren.
Wenn du es irgendwie schaffst, dass du deinem Handy Laptop
oder wenn du es irgendwie hinbekommst,
dass dein Handy Laptop die Mac-Adresse,
also die absende Mac-Adresse faked.
Ja, das würde funktionieren, wenn das Ganze denn natürlich...
Mac-basiert ist.
Es gibt ja noch verschiedene Port-Security-Varianten,
wenn du dich da zum Beispiel mit einem Passwort einloggen musst,
also mit einem Passwort und einem User,
beim Verbinden ins WLAN, dann könnte das sogar
WPA-Enterprise-Authentifizierung sein.
Also ist schwierig zu sagen, was es genau ist,
aber wenn das Mac-basiert ist, ja,
dann würde das eventuell funktionieren.
Allerdings musst du davon ausgehen, dass es nicht erlaubt ist.
Weil die Sache ist ja, die nur weil was funktioniert
und möglich ist, heißt es nicht unbedingt,
dass es gerne gesehen ist.
Aber gehen würde es wahrscheinlich.
Ich würde jetzt vielleicht nicht so weit gehen,
dass es illegal ist, dass du in den Knast kommst,
aber es ist sicherlich nicht erwünscht.
Okay, gucken wir das jetzt mal fertig.
Und die heißt Printing Diamonds.
Oh, das kenne ich.
Also wenn das das ist, was ich meine,
das ist ein Konsolenprogramm, wo du Diamant ausgeben musst.
Diese Buchstaben...
Ja, genau.
...Formationen ausdrucken.
Also wenn jetzt ein E kommt, dann soll der...
Ach das, jetzt weiß ich auch, was unsere Projektleiter
den ganzen Tag machen.
Jetzt ergibt das Sinn, jetzt weiß ich auch,
warum ich die nicht erreiche.
Die machen sowas.
...Diamant bis zum E aufgehen,
wenn der zum C kommt,
dann geht der Diamant nur bis zum C auf.
Wir nähern uns Schritt für Schritt
an den fertigen Algorithmus.
Die haben nicht mal Mauspads,
ich auf der Arbeit auch nicht.
Ach ja, das ist auch Fremdgerät fällt mir ein.
Ich habe meine Logitech G502
mit auf die Arbeit genommen,
das ist die mit dem Mausrad,
was man so aushängen kann.
Und ich habe jetzt wieder Fremdgerät,
das ist die mit dem Mausrad.
Und das machen wir, indem wir
immer einen Test schreiben,
den erfüllen und dann ist der nächste dran
mit dem nächsten Test.
Und so geht es reih um, das ist wie ein Spiel.
Oh, da hätte ich keinen Bock.
Mein Gott, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das wird mich ja richtig nerven,
wenn ich jeden Tag irgendwelche komischen
oder einmal in der Woche
auch schon irgendwelche komischen
Challenges machen muss, wo dann...
Oh nee, da hätte ich wirklich keinen Nerv drauf.
Also ich schreibe jetzt den ersten Test einfach.
Mein Chef weiß das,
dass ich jetzt die Maus dran habe.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
So kann man nicht machen.
Wisst ihr, was ich gemacht hätte?
Ich hätte es hardcoded.
Ich hätte einfach
den Beispielcode copy-pasted,
Console-Write-Line
oder kommt der Diamant raus.
Ich meine, das ist ein legitimer Versuch, ja?
Das ist ein absolut
bug-freies Programm.
Programme, die keinen Input haben
oder keinen dynamischen Ablauf,
können auch keine Bugs haben.
Also quasi
Immutable Programming.
Oh, das ist was.
Da sollte ich irgendein
Buch drüber schreiben.
Immutable Programming.
Das wird
der neueste Shit hier. Agil ist out.
Wir bauen jetzt einfach
nur Programme, wo jegliche
theoretisch mögliche Ausgabe
hardcoded schon drin ist. Dann sind zwar
die Programme 250TB groß,
aber sie sind
bug-frei, garantiert.
Immutable Static Coding.
Genau, so nennen wir das.
ISC.
Nee, P, nicht Coding Programming.
ISP. Nee, das ist schon
belegt. Da muss es ISC
heißen. Immutable Static Coding.
So machen wir das. Und wir machen es
wirklich rei um. Aber jetzt
ist es irgendwie ins Chaos
übergegangen.
Also Length ist gescheitert
und LetterRow
löst eine out of bounds
Exception aus.
Warum machen die das? Warum machen die denn Task?
Machen die das etwa Multithreaded?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Oder ist Task irgendwas
von diesem Testing? Ich würde sagen, das sieht
fast ein bisschen nach Multithreaded.
Wir geben das Programm Multithreaded
aus. Oder was gibt das,
wenn es fertig ist?
Task? Du?
Ach nee, Task ist wahrscheinlich eher das,
wo der Output reingestellt ist. Ach keine Ahnung, kein Schimmer.
Wir sprechen natürlich auch
in den
Fachbegriffen von den Programmierern
und ja, das ist dann
nicht immer für die Allgemeinheit
verständlich. Also Achtung,
der Test läuft.
Massive Test. Das ist grün geworden.
Also wir haben es jetzt nicht ganz
geschafft. Er macht noch nicht schöne Diamanten,
aber er macht immerhin die Buchstaben in der richtigen
Reihenfolge. Ich fand es sehr interessant,
weil ich habe die Aufgabe echt total
unterschätzt. Ich habe gedacht, wir haben echt
schwere Dojos geschafft und
so einfache Sachen
unterschätzt man tatsächlich schnell.
Dann hat sie es doch in sich gehabt.
Als nächstes
FizzBuzz in Assembler.
Ich arbeite 80%
weil ich gerne
Zeit habe für meine Kinder und
für meine Familie.
Und auch mir die Zeit
einräumen möchte,
damit ich Zeit habe, um Sport
zu machen und ein
ausgeglichenes Leben führen kann.
Wir spielen gerne
Rollenspiele, weil die Geschichte
immer weiter geht. Also
Real Life Brettspiele,
MonkaS. Es gibt halt Kapitel
und so wird diese
fantastische Geschichte
Abend zu Abend weiter gesponnen.
Ich zahle keine Miete hier.
Das Haus wurde von
meiner Mutter beschrieben.
Als ich aus der Schweiz
zurückkam, da
haben wir das Haus hier renoviert.
Das ist ja fast über mir.
Ich entdecke da einige Parallelen.
Das kostet halt für die Handwerker und das Material.
Ja.
Schauen wir mal, wo
er rumgeissen ist. Hier ist er.
Und schon ist er weg.
Also der
Hase, der darf auch... Was, der macht nicht
4 Tage, der macht 5 Tage, 6 Stunden.
Ja okay, aber
Arbeitszeit kommt ja aufs Gleiche raus.
Das ist ja das Wichtige an der Stelle.
Weil der kommt
selbstständig nach Hause.
Wenn er keine Lust mehr hat. Der ist schon
ein bisschen älter.
Oh nein,
Toss, Tossmusik.
Toss.
Ich muss das
rausholen.
Ich habe jetzt mal eine
ernst gemeinte Frage.
Wir haben jetzt seinen Tagesablauf so ein bisschen
gesehen. Aber
wann macht er denn mal
Projektleitung?
Beziehungsweise
Was
hat er denn so gearbeitet
den Tag über?
Wir haben ihn essen gesehen. Wir haben
ihn irgendwelche Coding-Challenges
machen sehen.
Smoothies kaufen.
Daily
Scrum haben sie gemacht.
Sorry, Daily Scrum haben sie gemacht. Aber
hat er in dem weiteren
noch irgendwas gearbeitet?
Der ist
ich meine, das ist dann schon
nice, oder, als Projektleitung, wenn du nur das
Daily Scrum machen musst.
Ach ja, neue Sitzeverteilung,
Algorithmus, stimmt.
Zweimal auf den Testbutton gedrückt. Ah ja,
okay, alles klar. Natürlich
ist es mehr. Solche Beiträge sind natürlich
immer nur
auch ein bisschen für die Noob-Zuschauer angepasst.
Die dann nicht wirklich was mit anfangen können, klar.
Natürlich wird er schon was machen und ich denke auch nicht,
dass er es schlecht macht oder so.
Du bist in der Abo-Falle,
richtig. Jetzt kommst du nicht raus.
Aber der große Vorteil von hier einem Prime-Sub
ist, dass, ich meine, es ist ja mittlerweile
also, erstens bekommt man hier einen nice Keks-
Avatar und hat
Zugriff auf so richtig
nice Emotes, wie zum Beispiel Wupp-Pock
oder Wupp-Pet
oder sowas, also beste
hier.
Und wir wissen auch, dass jeder Prime-Sub
den IQ des gesamten Chats steigert.
Aber nur um eins. Das heißt, es braucht
möglichst viele Prime-Subs, dass ihr auch mal irgendwann
exzellent Five Head werdet.
Aber es verfällt auch
mit der Zeit, also
wenn man nicht subscribt, dann geht's
wieder runter. Das ist ja nicht, das ist ja nicht statisch.
Kai, danke für den Sub. Simon auch.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Ich hab mich auf alle zugeschlagen.
Oder den da, ja.
Also wir haben schon einige, wir haben schon einige
Deskodes, danke schön für den Sub.
Wir haben schon einige coole Emotes
mittlerweile. Ich hab, ich hab glaub ich noch 11
freie Emote-Slots.
Ich sollte mal
plus, plus GIF-Emotes,
da sind auch noch welche frei und
Tier-2 und Tier-3-Emotes.
Das ist richtig.
Mir fällt das jedes Mal auf, ne?
Es ist ja aktuell bei mir, also jetzt
hab ich eh Urlaub bis Januar, aber
bei mir ist es so, ich geh Dienstags immer nach
Frankfurt auf die Arbeit, Rest des Homeoffice.
Und mir fällt immer auf,
wie unglaublich
ineffektiv das ist im Büro.
Du bist da so viel am
schwätzen, dann kommt irgend einer vorbei und fragt
hier, wie sieht's aus? Dann bist du mit dem eine halbe Stunde am
labbern, dann kommst du morgens rein, ja hier
Max, wie geht's? Hast du Diablo 2 weitergespielt?
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung? Ja, ja und
wie sieht's bei dir aus? Ja und, ist irgendwas
passiert die letzten Tage? Ja, Diggs hier ist
ausgefallen, ja was war's denn gewesen?
Dann wird ein bisschen über die Bahn geflamed,
dann ist
Wartungsarbeiten-Runde,
dann ist Daily-Runde,
dann ist
Dokumentations-Runde,
dann ist Team-Runde,
was auch immer alles, also im Prinzip
ich mach den Tag über, wenn ich
im Büro bin, nichts.
Und es ist gar nicht so, als würde ich drauf anlegen,
aber es geht einfach nichts vorwärts.
Ich mach eigentlich die drei Tage,
wo ich daheim bin,
das, was ich die anderen
Tage nicht machen kann.
Ich wohne nicht in Frankfurt,
ich wohne in Hanau.
In welchem Viertel man wohnen sollte, das kann
ich dir gar nicht so genau sagen.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, welche Ecken nicht so
geil sind. So
wie in der Strasse.
Da will man nicht hin, aber
ansonsten.
Kommt drauf, ah nee, ist so schlimm, ist das nicht.
Also Leute, die ich da kenne und die ich mag,
mit denen labere ich auch von mir aus mal.
Mosel-Eck, Mosel-Eck, ja Mosel-Eck
ist auch richtig, beste Mosel-Eck.
Mosel-Eck.
Es gibt, muss ich mal kurz sagen,
hier, warte mal, Mosel-Eck,
Frankfurt, ich zeige jetzt
was, wo man tatsächlich richtig
nice, finde ich, was zu Mittag essen kann, was auch
günstig ist. Nicht Mosel-Eck,
ich meine nicht das Wort, nee, aber Mosel-Eck.
Mosel-Eck ist so ziemlich die schlimmste Kneipe, die man sich vorstellen kann
in Frankfurt. Ich war da noch nie drinne,
ich kenne das nur von außen und es sieht
immer äußerst abschreckend aus.
Aber neben dem Mosel-Eck gibt
es auch nicht Kabul-Restaurant,
sondern
da gibt es so einen
Metzger, der aber irgendwie
nicht angezeigt wird, ist der vielleicht weiter unten?
Hier.
Was? Nein.
Wo ist er schon? Doch, hier.
Hier, Flasche. Das ist echt nice.
Die haben richtig
fette Frikadellenbrötchen und
Eberkäsebrötchen, wenn man sowas macht,
macht für irgendwie 1,20 Euro
oder so. Und wenn man da 1,2
futtert, isst man richtig satt
und kommt günstig weg.
Ich pepo, pepo-Fat.
Der fette Bulle.
Der Laden, den
hätte ich fast mal, jetzt
Realtor, mit dem hätte ich fast
mal ein Burger-Sponsoring
gemacht. Kein Spaß.
Wir waren da kurz
davor, ich hab sogar schon E-Mails mit
denen ausgetauscht.
Weiß nicht, ob man das
noch auf Twitter sieht.
Was?
Hashtag Twitter
Hure, was ist denn hier los?
Ok, nach diesem, das ist
eine Antwort auf mein,
das ist eine Antwort auf mein, äh,
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Ich muss das jetzt auf Twitter, ich muss das jetzt
schneller auf Twitter raussuchen, Leute.
Twitter.
Ja, hier.
Guckt hier, mit denen war ich kurz
davor,
mit denen war ich kurz davor, mal ein
Burger,
ein Burger-Sponsoring
abzuschließen.
Ich war bei denen mal, da hab ich geschrieben,
richtig nice, Alter, gebt mir jeden Tag ein
neuer und ich poste euch ersten an 20.000 Leute
Deal. Und da war der Deal steht.
Und ich hab mit denen auch schon E-Mails
getauscht, aber haben wir da nie gemacht.
Sieht aber echt gut aus, also es kann nicht
schlechter laden, zumindest das letzte Mal, wo ich da war.
Das dürfte auch eines der letzten Male gewesen
sein und Scheiß, wo ich da war.
Ich, ich
versuche seit ein paar Jahren schon
nicht mal ganz so ungesundes Zeug zu furtern.
Ich mein, ich weiß, ihr kennt meine Bilder auf
Twitter und so manchmal, das
sieht vielleicht nicht so aus, aber ich versuche
nicht dicker
zu werden und ich versuche auch etwas
gesünder zu leben, die letzten paar Jahre schon.
Was man ja auch an Bewegung
und allem sieht, aber
natürlich
gibt's da immer noch viel zu
viel zu machen.
Versuch,
ja versuchen schon,
bei mir klappt es ja auch nicht richtig.
Ok, jetzt haben wir uns das
angeguckt. Was haben wir denn als nächstes hier?
Der Null-Euro-Isch bei PC.
Weiß ich gar nicht, warum ich das
aufgemacht hab, aber in der
Tiffel klang ja 200
Pfoff in Modern Warfare, Sekunde, ich will nur kurz
angucken, wie 200 Pfoff aussehen.
Boah, da bist du ja schlecht bei.
Boah, da kriegst du ja Motion Signis.
Guckt euch mal die Waffe an,
von der ist ja kaum was übrig.
Honka S.
Äh, ne, das will ich nicht gucken.
Was passiert, was, was passiert,
wenn die Erde aus dem Sonnensystem fliegt?
Ich glaub, das ist nicht gut für uns.
Also was auch immer dann genau passiert,
es ist auf jeden Fall,
geht es für uns nicht gut aus.
Es wird kühl, ja.
Smart Backyard, oh man, Handy klingelt,
was ist da los?
Oh, oh, guck mal, es gibt neue,
es gibt neue Emotes für,
hab ich grad gelesen, im, per,
per PN auf
Twitter.
Ach ne, doch nicht.
Ist doch noch nicht fertig, okay.
Die Nachte sind fertig mittlerweile.
Battlefee, oh, die GameStar hat da auch
ein Video zugemacht.
Wenn die GameStar hat mal ein Video geguckt.
Ne, glaub ich nicht.
Wir schauen mal, wer das Ganze moderiert.
Landscape, danke für den, für den Sub.
Ja, ich hab's schon gesehen,
ich hab's schon gesehen,
danke für den Sub.
Wer, wer moderiert?
Es ist Maurice und Dimitri.
Dimitri.
Dann gucken wir das Video.
Das ist gut.
Die zwei besten von der GameStar.
Rest kann ich mir nicht geben,
na, das stimmt nicht, das ist übertrieben, aber
es gibt ein paar, die ich mir nicht geben kann,
aber die zwei sind die besten.
Gibt es in Frankfurt gute lokale DSL-Anbieter?
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber du hast in Frankfurt selbst gute Chancen,
Glasfaserstelle zum Beispiel von
Vodafone zu kriegen.
Ich muss mal kurz die Lautstärke checken.
Man muss lauter.
Ja.
Launch, Bugs und Sachen,
dass man sich nicht reviven kann,
dass man nicht redeployen kann,
Performance-Probleme,
was ist denn mit der Lautstärke hier los?
Wie man sich in einem Patch auch relativ zeitnah
kümmern könnte.
Und es gibt diesen beiden Bereich, das sind eher
auf Design-Ebene tiefliegendere...
Ist ja das, was ich in meinem Video auch gesagt hab.
...weil im Titan, zum Beispiel beim
Waffenverhalten,
bei den Inhalten, beim Balancing und so weiter.
Scheint schon was dran zu sein, wenn die es bei der GameStar auch erzählen.
Ich hab jetzt schon einen Patch,
der hat sich um das
Rubberbanding gekümmert, was ein großes Problem war.
Also es gab so eine
Proximity-Scanner
und den musste man erstmal
freischalten und als dann immer mehr Leute
angefangen haben diesen Proximity-Scanner freizuschalten,
haben sie gemerkt, dass
die Server zum einen Sturz...
Ich hab ja persönlich eine andere Vermutung
mit dem Motion-Sensor.
Ich hab vermutet,
also hat sich jetzt nicht bewahrheitet,
aber ich hab gedacht, den haben die wegen
XP-Boosting rausgeschmissen.
Und wollten das irgendwie
patchen, haben sie aber nicht.
...bringt beziehungsweise für dieses Rubberbanding so auf...
Richtig nice Werbung!
Guck mal hier, da habt ihr es gesehen, der Ice-T.
...haben sie gemerkt, dass die Server
zum einen Sturz bringt beziehungsweise...
Er redet nicht vom Motion-Sensor, doch, doch.
Macht er.
Guck mal hier, richtig Porgas Ice-T-Werbung.
Ganz
unauffällig. Sind die gesponsert vom Ice-T?
...
Nein.
Also haben sie dieses Feature wieder entfernt,
dieses Gadget entfernt.
Und jetzt dieser Patch kümmert sich darum, dass dieses Rubberbanding
komplett wegfliegt.
Was man interessanterweise sieht, ist, dass DICE
jetzt viel, viel direkter als früher
eingreifen kann in die Spiele.
Dass sie zum Beispiel Gadgets von
Operatorn entfernt haben jetzt in der letzten Woche.
Das wäre so früher nicht möglich gewesen.
Also sie können das im Moment tun, ohne
direkt einen riesigen kleinen Patch machen
zu müssen. Was cool ist prinzipiell,
aber viele, viele Probleme
sind noch da. Das Testevent,
du hattest es ja auch schon in deinen ersten Fazit
geschrieben. Maurice ist etwas asynchron
gerade.
War jetzt dezent gesagt.
Ach doch, guck mal, das ist der Ice-T Hersteller.
Die sind tatsächlich, die sponsoren
das tatsächlich. Nice. Das brauche ich
auch, Leute. Dann sauf ich jeden Tag
hier so einen Ice-T und erzähle, wie geil der ist.
Nicht so geil.
Da konnte man in sehr begrenzter Zeit
nur immer festgelegte Modi relativ
kurz spielen.
Was ja, wie du auch eben gesagt hast, gar
nicht reicht, um ein Spiel wie Battlefield
abschließend zu beurteilen.
Jetzt ist es ja schon eine Woche lang
in der Wildnis sozusagen.
Wo es Leute in dieser... Was? Ich muss
da keine Facecam anmachen.
Ich trinke das einfach und blende
irgendwie ein Bild davon ein und
sagt dann, oh Ice-T, exquisite, exquisite
Ice-T. Und das
geht schon.
Also mich würde echt mal interessieren,
wie Maurice das gemacht hat. Maurice hat krass
abgenommen. Wenn sich Videos... Guckt euch Videos
vor zwei Jahren an. Und ist richtig,
richtig krass in Form mittlerweile.
Das hätte ich, würde ich auch so gut hinkriegen.
Gerne.
... länger spielen konnten. Haben sich da noch
Dinge entwickelt oder ergeben, die man
im Testevent noch nicht so auf dem Schirm hatte?
Auch bei dir selber zum Beispiel. Ja, einige.
Also auf der positiven Seite, was man sagen kann,
Hazard Zone funktioniert besser,
als ich gedacht hätte, dass es funktionieren
würde. Ja, da war ich ja sehr, sehr kritisch
nach dem Testevent. Hab auch gesagt, dass die
KI zu heftig ist. Das haben...
Und ich verstehe das auch, weil es ein bisschen
unpräzise formuliert war von mir. Da haben Leute gedacht,
okay, die mir ist zu blöd, auf die KI-Gegner
zu schießen. Das war nicht das Problem.
Die snipen dich manchmal instant. Ich halte sie für
zu penetrant. Sie schießen halt auf 200
Meter, fangen sie an, dich zu behagen.
Sie schießen durch Softcover durch.
Also sie gehen einem in Hazard Zone... KI ist dumm.
... die ganze Zeit auf den Keks. Bei einem Modus,
der eigentlich auf PvP ausgelegt ist
und auch in einem Modus, wo man... Dass es Bots gibt,
ist einfach dumm.... die KI nicht nutzen kann,
um beispielsweise anderen Gegner
interessante Fallen zu stellen oder so.
Also das war quasi die Kritik an Hazard Zone
und dass es halt kein gutes
Balancing hat für Einsteiger. Jetzt habe ich
nach Release viele Runden Hazard Zone gespielt
und hatte da deutlich mehr Spaß
als beim Review-Event.
Und die Leute finden den Modus auch...
Ich sag mal, es gibt viele Leute, die den Modus
ganz cool finden. Ich bleibe nach wie vor dabei,
dass das kein Warzone-Killer ist und ich bleibe...
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, also allein schon,
dass du das Spiel dafür kaufen musst,
ist schwierig bei Hazard Zone.
Und das steht und fällt
wie bei vielem in diesem Game. Einfach
was sie jetzt an Content noch liefern.
Wie gesagt, ich bin da mal in einem Spiel, der hat viele
richtig grundlegende
Probleme.
Also im Kern tiefgreifende
Probleme. Aber
wenn man da jetzt Content bringt,
der den Namen Battlefield auch verdient hat,
ist es nicht so, als könnte man da nicht noch
irgendwas draus machen.
Ich bleibe nach wie vor dabei, dass sich zeigen muss,
ob dieser Modus langfristig spannend bleibt
oder nicht schnell zu langweilig wird.
Aber das quasi auf der haben Seite.
Auf der negativen Seite haben sich natürlich noch
viele Probleme herauskristallisiert, die
ich so nach dem Review Event noch nicht auf dem Schirm hatte.
Zum Beispiel gibt es massive
Balancing-Probleme bei den Waffen. Also aktuell
spielen halt alle Leute eine ganz spezielle
Maschinenpistole. PP-K29.
Und meinetwegen noch eine LMG. Und ansonsten
durch diesen Weapon-Bloom. Alles gleiche.
Dass es ein Stück weit zufallsbasiert
ist, wie sehr deine Waffe
streut. Serious Max, willst du
nachher mitspielen Hazard Zone? Ich muss Hazard
Zone aufnehmen. Ich muss morgen noch
einen Sponsor und Video Hazard Zone machen. Das Letzte,
wozu ich zugestimmt habe. Duzt ihr euch
auf der Arbeit zum Kirsten halt schon?
Z.B. dass bestimmte
Sturmgewehre relativ nutzlos sind.
Das Waffenmeter ist gerade bei
den ohnehin schon 22 Waffen.
So kaputt,
dass im Prinzip nur 3-4 Waffen überhaupt
gespielt werden von den meisten
Leuten. Was schon mal ein Problem ist.
Und dann gibt es auch noch viele Bugs, die wir nicht
gesehen haben. Man kann aktuell mit Schlauchbooten
vertikal Wände hochfahren. Also
ich bin jetzt kein Experte.
Da muss ich aber sagen,
also natürlich ist es bescheuert und ich glaube gar
nicht mal, dass es wirklich Absicht ist, dass
man vertikal mit dem Mavacraft die Wände hochfahren kann.
Aber in Anbetracht
der Tatsache, dass in Breakthrough
die
Flaggen
absolut kacke unbalanced
sind für die
Attacker, finde ich, das ist
eine legitime Sache, das im Spiel
zu lassen.
Dakat, du hast ja keine Chance, die
Hochhäuser einzunehmen. Mit einem Havacraft hast du
wenigstens ein bisschen mehr die Chance.
Im echten Leben nicht,
aber in Battlefield funktioniert das, dass du einfach
mit dem Schlauchboot einen Wolkenkratzer
hochfahren kannst. Und dann
kristallisiert sich auch... Das finde ich aber irgendwie auch
geil. Natürlich, es ist cool, wenn man
einen Schlauchbootsimulator hat. Bei Battlefield
ist das nicht so geil. Und die Breakthrough
Matches haben auch... Ich muss euch sagen, ich finde es auch
nicht schlecht. Ich finde das eigentlich gar
keine schlechte Mechanik, auch wenn es wahrscheinlich nicht
so toll ist. Wenn die Dinger nicht so maßlos
OP wären, und wenn
Breakthrough besser gebalanced wäre,
dann könnte man sagen, hey, lassen wir raus. Aber
du hast jetzt schon in Breakthrough keine Chance,
die Hochhäuser einzunehmen. Egal ob
auf Orbital, ob auf
Kaleidoskop oder Hourglass.
Wie kriegt man die Dinger einfach
B drücken? Also entweder rein spawnen, wenn es was gibt,
eins auf der Map finden oder B drücken und
sich in Havacraft spawnen. Auf
Orbital enden alle Matches gleich.
Es sagt das ja.
Genau.
Hourglass und Kaleidoskop
auch.
Einer von den zwei großen All-out-Warfare-Modi.
Schlimme Probleme, weil die Matches
alle zu Defender
lastig sind. Also die Verteidiger gewinnen
sehr oft. Da hat Dice auch jetzt schon an den Tickets
gedreht. Aber ich sage mal,
du kannst nur so viel an Zahlen
drehen in einem Spiel, wenn das Problem
eigentlich im Map-Design liegt.
Da musst du eigentlich am Map-Design
ändern. Und das ist eins von diesen
schwerwiegenden Sachen, wo sie
noch mal tiefer rein müssten.
Wieso sagen die Schlauchboote, wenn es
Havacraft sind? Ich finde, das ist nichts, wo man sich
jetzt groß irgendwie aufregen müsste.
Das ist alles jetzt noch nicht passiert.
Und das wird auch noch eine Weile dauern,
bis sowas passiert. Wenn überhaupt.
Oder wird alsbald was
passieren bei
Voice-Chat und Punktetafel.
Denn das ging ja erstmal ohne beides.
Also wenn wir ehrlich sind,
das ist zum größten Teil absichtlich, wie es ist.
Gerade was Scoreboard und sowas angeht.
Eventuell wird das geändert, weil der Aufschrei so groß ist.
Übrigens wieder zur Hälfte, die hier Bots gekillt hat.
Nice. Achso, das ist noch aus dem
Review-Event. Okay.
F***, jetzt habe ich den veran verloren. Was hat er gesagt?
Punktetafel.
Achja, also
das ist Absicht. Vielleicht war der Aufschrei jetzt so groß,
dass die das mit dem Scoreboard und so nochmal
überarbeiten.
Aber
also bei der Geschwindigkeit von
Dice, was Content angeht,
müssen sie diesmal echt eine Schippe drauflegen.
Wenn sie das nicht machen, ist
gelaufen. Weil ganz
ehrlich, in diesem Zustand
wird das Spiel wahrscheinlich nicht mal großartig
bis nächstes Jahr überleben.
Jetzt, ich sage euch
wie es ist. Die haben ja angekündigt,
sie wollen erst nächstes Jahr die erste Season starten.
Und
also
in der ersten Season müsste ja
massive Content kommen, wenn das
weiterhin interessant bleiben sollte.
Die haben kaum Waffen, die haben kaum Maps,
die haben kaum Spielmodi. Was
wollen die denn bringen in ihrem Season Pass?
Weil
es bringt ja nichts, wenn du jetzt irgendwie
super geile Skins und Animationen
drops, wenn du das Spiel eigentlich nicht
spielen willst oder nicht mehr spielen willst
oder was auch immer. Also die müssten
theoretisch das Spiel jetzt ein halbes Jahr
jede, die müssten theoretisch jede Woche
einen krassen Patch liefern.
Die müssten quasi so einen
Weekly Patch Day haben, wo die Leute
richtig drauf geiern und sich freuen.
Und das fürs nächste halbe Jahr.
Dann kämen da vielleicht
irgendwas raus.
Dinge erstmal ohne beides an den Start.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass mit der Punktetafel war auch eine bewusste
Entscheidung. Definitiv.
Es war die falsche Entscheidung. Man weiß
jetzt noch nicht, wie schnell sie das fixen werden.
Aber sie haben schon im Review Event
uns gesagt, dass diese Dinge angegangen
werden. Genau wie Voice IP Chat. Also ich gehe mal davon aus...
Ja Moment. Also Dimitri, da muss ich
sagen, ich war auch bei diesen Events
dabei. Und gerade beim
ersten, gerade beim
allerersten Event, da haben die
Dinge erzählt, die überhaupt nicht gekommen sind.
Da haben sie zum Beispiel...
Was haben sie uns erzählt? Man kann
die Maps anpassen.
In Warsaw haben sie...
In Portal haben sie glaube ich erzählt.
Da müsste ich mir jetzt mal Gedanken darüber machen.
Also die haben da einige Dinge erzählt, die nie so gekommen
sind. Also
vielleicht wollten sie es machen, durften dann nicht, hatten
keine Zeit, was auch immer.
Ich gebe da
auf die Aussagen noch relativ
wenig. Ich warte wirklich erst
drauf, bis es denn auch ernsthaft
passiert.
Es steht bei Ihnen, das ist ein bisschen
Spekulation, aber es steht bei Ihnen sehr weit oben
auf der Agenda, hinter
diesen ganzen Bugs und Performance-Problemen.
Weil das muss natürlich Priorität
eins haben, dass die Leute das Spiel überhaupt
mal spielen können, bevor sie sich
um sowas wie das Scoreboard kümmern werden.
Aber ich bin jetzt mal vorsichtig optimistisch,
dass diese Sachen noch dieses Jahr gefixt werden.
Don't quote me.
Ich hoffe, DICE
muss das fixen. Die Sache
ist nur die, wenn die so lahm sind wie die letzten
Battlefields.
Tja, mal gucken.
Wie setzt die Performance so
in der Wildnis, wie gesagt, wenn haufenweise Leute
sie alle auf ihrem eigenen Setup das Spiel
spielen können? Was hast du so gehört von Leuten?
Sie ist nicht so gut, wie sie sein müsste.
Gemessen daran, wie auch
die Engine in der Vergangenheit
Okay, der kritisiert das Game ja ein bisschen. Natürlich
ein bisschen zurückhaltender wie ich. Das ist ganz
klar. Ich hab's ja da teilweise auch echt ein bisschen
übertrieben. Ich gucke mal, wie die
Bewertung und Dislikes sind.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man das
Disliked.
Naja.
Er hat ja recht, komplett mit allem, was
er sagt.
Seht ihr, es ist wichtig,
dass wir Dislikes haben auf YouTube.
Schonende Engine,
die auch auf älteren Systemen gut läuft.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Battlefield bei allen
Leuten unmöglich läuft. Also wir haben
mit einer 3070, mit einer 3080,
auch mit einer 2080
kommt man schon auf seine 60, 70, 80 Frames.
Also kein Problem ist zu viel gesagt.
Also es ist lauffähig,
dass man schon auf seine 60, 70, 80
Frames kommt.
Ich hab wahrscheinlich noch
das nicht abbekommen.
Das YouTube rollt das ja immer in Wellen aus.
Das hab ich nicht zugehört, Zack.
Die auch auf älteren Systemen gut läuft.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Battlefield bei allen Leuten
unmöglich läuft. Also wir haben
mit einer 3070, mit einer 3080,
also es ist lauffähig,
aber
Flutschen ist was anderes.
Das Traumergebnis, wenn du
halt so gute GPUs
hast, dann solltest du
auf mehr Bilder pro Sekunde kommen
können. Aber ich sag mal, das reicht, um das Spiel
spielbar zu machen. Gleichzeitig auf
älteren Systemen, also ist es
schwierig, schwierig, schwierig.
Na gut, meinst du, es ist vier Jahre alt, gar
kein Problem. Wir haben jetzt sehr negative Erfahrungen
gemacht. Da gibt es aber auch einen Technikcheck auf der Games.
Ich hab eine 1080P, überhaupt kein Problem
läuft. Läuft echt
ganz brauchbar. Aber natürlich
für Low Settings
ist jetzt halt auch nicht das,
was man sehen will. Also Low Settings würde ich auch
mehr erwarten.
Und ich spiele 1080P.
Das ist kein Problem, was per se
an den Grafiken oder den CPUs.
Sie müssen dringend per Patch am Spiel
selbst nochmal fixen, wie
die CPU-Auslastung versus GPU-Auslastung
ist, wie auch die Unterschiede
sind, wenn du halt die Grafikeinstellung veränderst, dass es da
einfach mehr Spielraum gibt, um FPS zu
boosten. Also das Spiel ist einfach noch
nicht optimiert genug,
um halt auf möglichst vielen Rechnern zu laufen.
Jetzt hast du im Grunde jede meiner Fragen
mit, ja ja, da muss DICE wirklich noch
dran arbeiten beantwortet.
Wenn du jetzt hier der Chef von
DICE wärst, wie würdest du priorisieren?
Okay Leute, welchen Brand
löschen wir als erstes?
Ich antworte jetzt einfach mal
davor, weil ich weiß nicht, was er sagt.
Wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Also, wenn ich da wirklich, die haben ja
massig Entwickler, die haben ja massig
Entwickler am Start, selbst wenn davon
jetzt nur noch ein Bruchteil da ist,
Post-Release, wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Ich würde mir
den Großteil der Leute nehmen,
sag mal 70% würde ich nehmen,
um das Spiel zu polieren, dass
es gut läuft, dass die Bugs
behoben werden und sonst was, dass ich meine Spieler nicht
weiter enttäusche. So.
Aber ich würde mir 20-30%
der Entwickler nehmen,
die natürlich agil mit Daily Scrum
und Scrum Master,
die die Inhalte, die da drin sind,
noch anderweitig nutzbar
machen. Also ich würde zum Beispiel
dafür sorgen, dass man in Portal-Map-Zonen setzen kann,
aber das, was ich als allererstes
machen würde oder was ich den Leuten als allererstes
sagen würde, ist, nehmt die Maps,
die drin sind
und macht aus jeder
Map, sucht euch die coolsten Areale
raus, von den Maps,
die schon drin sind. Also die Maps
haben ja durchaus die ein oder anderen
coolen Areale, zum Beispiel
sogar Breakaway. Breakaway
hat das Areal an der Plattform, was ganz
nice ist. Breakaway hat das Areal mit
diesen, was ist denn das, diesen
halbrunden Häusern, das ganz nice ist.
Hourglass hat das Stadion und so
was in der Richtung. Sucht euch Areale
raus auf den Maps, die ganz cool sind
und macht aus jeder Map
1 bis 3,
dazu musst du nix machen, du musst einfach
nur Map-Begrenzungen ziehen, sonst nix,
also das ist kein großer Aufwand.
Macht aus
den Maps jeweils 1 bis 3
coole, kleinere,
32,
64 spielbare
Varianten, also
1 bis 3
Areale
rausschneiden aus diesen Maps, das kann
die gleiche Map sein. Wie gesagt, man muss ja nur
Map-Begrenzungen setzen
und daraus dann
32 bzw.
48, 64 Spieler
Areale
machen.
Das würde glaube ich denen
die klassische Battlefield Info,
also natürlich auch mit weniger Fahrzeugen,
also
also denen,
die nicht so auf diesen ultra krassen
128 Spieler Clusterfuck stehen,
den Spielern wird das was geben.
Und dann würde ich auch Domination
noch draufsetzen, oder eben
Smalles oder Normales Conquest.
Sag mal so, Domination
und Conquest,
ich lehne mich jetzt mal etwas aus dem Fenster, ich weiß die hardcore
Battlefield Fans werden mich nicht zustehen, ist doch sehr
ähnlich.
Von der Mechanik her.
Du hältst das, bei Domination
bekommst du Punkte, bei
Conquest gibt es Ticketabzüge und so, aber
es geht aufs Ähnliche.
Kommt aufs Ähnliche raus.
Und einfach 3 Flaggen,
vielleicht 4, je nachdem wie das Areal
ist,
platzieren und daraus schöne
32, 48, 64
Mann, also
ich will die gleichen Areale nehmen,
spielbare Areale
machen.
Und dafür halt einfach
eine neue Playlist machen.
So.
Das wäre so easy zu machen.
Und dazu würde ich
30% von meinem Team abstellen,
alle anderen würde ich erstmal an Bugfixes und vor allem
Quality of Life Sachen arbeiten lassen.
Zum Beispiel
Map Selection und sowas in der Richtung.
Und
das würde ich dann relativ schnell droppen, weil das
kein großer Aufwand ist.
Und dann würde ich irgendwie versuchen,
dass mit
sinkender Bug-Anzahl
und grundlegenden großen Problemen
des Games würde ich versuchen immer mehr Leute
zu schiften, von dem reinen
Bug-Fixing-Polierteam.
Da brauchst du natürlich immer eine
Zahl, bis wir vielleicht mal so ankommen
bei 70-30, also 70%
für neue coole Sachen und 30%
die sich permanent um Balancing
Bugs und sonst was kümmern. Aber wahrscheinlich
bin ich da einfach nicht
Projektmanager genug und natürlich würde es wahrscheinlich
so, wie ich das sage, gar nicht funktionieren, weil ich auch keine
Erfahrung damit habe. Aber so würde ich es wahrscheinlich
machen. Ok, mal gucken was Dimitri sagt.
Die haben 90%
entwickelt abgesucht. Ich rede ja von den
verbleibenden. Guck mal, die hatten so viele,
10% der verbleibende sind immer noch mehr
als viele Studios überhaupt haben.
Ich würde tatsächlich zuerst die ganzen
Bugs angehen, was sie glaube ich auch machen werden,
dass die Revive-Bug weg ist. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob der Patch das jetzt schon fixt. Es steht nicht in den
Patch-Notes, aber ich hoffe es einfach,
weil das halt super nervige Sachen sind.
Es gibt auch so, danach
würde ich mich sofort um diese Komfort-Features kümmern.
Ja, korrekt.
Wenn du 5-6 Leute hast, dann
es können ja nur 4 Leute in Squad. Du kannst
auch keine Party bilden, die größer ist als
4 Leute. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht, wir hatten das Ding, dass Mary die Fünfte war,
Kollegin Mary, und uns joinen wollte und
sie konnte nicht joinen, also nicht auf
demselben Server spielen wie wir. Richtig
pippiger Gramm. Hier, hier!
Das hatte selbst Battlefront 2. Das ist die
Fahne, die ich meine, in meinem Video
als Beispiel. Hier, hier sieht man es
endlich mal.
Hier ist nichts!
Leute, guckt euch das an!
Was ist das für einen Raum?
Das ist der liebloseste Battlefield-Bunker,
Battlefield-Raum, den ich je gesehen habe.
Das hat einfach nur weiße Wände
und zwei Pflanzen drin. Da ist nichts!
Weiße Wände, weißer Boden,
weiße Decke, weiße
was auch immer, Felsen
da drin, ich weiß nicht mal, was das sein soll,
und zwei Büsche.
Das ist eines der lieblosesten Räume,
langweiligsten Räume, die ich je gesehen habe
auf der Battlefield-Map.
Es gibt jetzt genug Leute, die sagen wahrscheinlich,
ja, das ist noch viel schlimmer an manchen Stellen der Map,
das stimmt, aber ich finde, das hier ist richtig
sinnbildlich, zumal du auch Probleme hast, du siehst
Leute laufen hinter der Wand, weil das Licht durchklitscht
und sowas.
Das ist die Feature, das hatte selbst
Battlefront 2. Nichts ist da drin, nichts!
Battlefront 2 war jetzt nun beileibe kein Feature-Fest.
Sowas muss möglich sein, dass ich mit fünf
Freunden zusammen eine Party gründe im Spiel,
dass wir uns genauso wie er unterhalten,
und dass wir auch auf demselben Server joinen,
dass wir halt nicht im selben Squad sind.
Auch, dass man den Squad ändert, das geht ja gar nicht,
das funktioniert nicht. Wenn du im Squad landest,
auch als Solospieler, wo halt alle Leute
nur Tank spielen, und du möchtest aber lieber
eine Front anpumpen,
dann kannst du deinen Squad nicht ändern.
Das sind solche Basic Features,
die einfach drin sein müssen
und so schnell wie möglich da rein gehören.
Datum würde ich mich kümmern, und danach
würde ich schauen, dass so schnell wie möglich
diese erste Season mit spannenden Inhalten anläuft.
Das muss man einfach sagen. Die große
Probe, die DICE jetzt hat, ist ja,
dass sie zeigen müssen,
dass sie systemisch in der Lage sind,
so ein Service-Game jetzt genauso am Laufen
zu halten, wie das 2021 notwendig ist.
Das ist auch was, Chet,
ihr habt komplett recht, das kommt auch noch
dabei, zu dem, was er sagt.
Das Umgedrehte sollte auch gehen,
dass man Solo spielen kann, wenn man denn wirklich
will. Also, dass ich sagen kann,
hey, ich möchte in einem Squad alleine
sein. Das ist auch cool,
wenn das gehen würde.
Nicht, dass sie keine Spiele machen können.
Es sind immer systemische Probleme,
die sie zurückhalten. Bei Battlefront waren
es die Filme, dass sie halt für das
Olle Episode 8 und für Solo-Content
machen mussten und nicht das machen konnten,
was sie wollten. Bei Battlefield 5
haben sie ihren Battle Royale halt
sterben lassen müssen, weil Criterion abgezogen
wurde für ein anderes Projekt. Und jetzt
müssen sie dringend zeigen, dass das
gefixt ist, dass sie jetzt
wirklich wie ein modernes Service-Game
reagieren können auf Probleme.
Ich hab da so meine Zweifel.
Ich hab so meine Zweifel.
Genau das, das sage ich
auch die ganze Zeit und da muss ich ihm voll und ganz
recht geben. Die Season 1
ist der, also der
späteste, quasi, wie
könnte man das ausdrücken?
Mir fällt kein gescheites Wort.
Der letzte mögliche Knackpunkt in
diesem, oder, oder...
Wie nennt man das? So ab, wo es
dann nicht mehr hoch ging. Also, wenn das
jetzt auch noch verkackt wird. Also,
Season 1 ist der letztmögliche
Punkt, wo sie
das Spiel nochmal drehen könnten.
Point of no re... So was in der
Richtung, genau. Also, wenn die
Season 1 auch sackt,
ist vorbei. Do or die.
Genau.
Sieht das echt schlecht aus, weil die Konkurrenz schläft nicht.
Siehst du darin auch ein
großes Problem jetzt für das Spiel, dass diese
Season ja nach hinten verschoben wurde?
Oder glaubst du, jetzt zumindest bis dahin
ist kaputt? Die haben ja gesagt, Januar,
oder, nee, die haben nicht mal gesagt Januar. Die haben gesagt,
glaube ich, sogar erstes Quartal nur,
gesagt für
2022.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Spieler überhaupt
bei der Stange bleiben, bis die erste Season am Start
ist. Content schon da, um
die Leute bei der Stange zu halten.
Das ist die spannende Frage.
Es kommt drauf an, wie schnell
bis dahin der Patch kommt. Also, ich glaube, dass sie,
wenn sie jetzt die Sachen fixen,
dass die Community nicht wegläuft, nur weil jetzt
keine neue Map kommt bis Januar. Das
glaube ich schon. Und auch der Battle Pass,
ich halte es jetzt für kein
Riesenproblem, wenn da jetzt nicht sofort der Battle
Pass am Start ist, weil die Leute ja erstmal ihre Waffen
freischalten und so.
Leute, ich habe nicht
so viel gespielt.
Der Lost, der hat ja jeden Tag 12
Stunden gegrindet. Der hat alles
unlockt. Ich habe jetzt nicht so viel gespielt.
Weil es ein neues Battlefield ist,
doch schon einiges gespielt, aber nicht so viel.
Ich habe auch schon fast alles
frei. Also,
es ist einfach nicht viel drin. Also, ich glaube,
es ist zu spät, wenn das
erst nächstes Jahr kommt. Und
es ist ja nicht mal gesagt, dass es direkt am Anfang von nächstem Jahr
kommt.
Es sind zwar nur 22 Waffen, aber
es ist ja zumindest noch ein bisschen was,
was man freischalten kann. Trotzdem
ist so meine größte Sorge, dass
Battlefield den Leuten zu schnell langweilig werden
könnte. Also, ich finde, man
kann mit diesem Spiel Spaß haben. Ich habe mit diesem Spiel
auch schon viele coole Matches gehabt.
Gerade so die Conquest Partien, wenn man
dann irgendwie im Schlauchboot in die gegnerische Basis fährt.
Und auch, wie gesagt, diese Hazard Zone Runden
und auch mit den Portal Maps, mit diesen alten Maps
kann man sehr viel Spaß haben. Ich bin
mir nur unsicher, ob nicht dann, wenn
man halt mit 20 Schlauchbooten 20
Mal in eine Basis gefahren ist, ob man dann nicht
an den Punkt rauskommt, wo man sagt, okay,
jetzt habe ich halt alle Waffen gespielt.
Es ist irgendwann auch mal gut, genau.
Jetzt habe ich auch die Strategien durchprobiert.
Ich habe alle Maps gesehen. Die Maps sind ja
auch sehr ähnlich vom Layout. Das sind alles
halt sehr weite Maps mit vielen
langen Distanzgefechten.
Bei Hazard Zone schwimme ich im Geld.
Da habe ich jetzt auch eigentlich kein Ziel mehr, irgendwas
zu machen. Und bei Portal habe ich jetzt die alten
Maps gespielt. Der Editor,
ja, die XP-Farben haben
sie ja eh abgeschaltet.
Da gibt es jetzt auch nicht so viel, was mich interessiert.
Irgendwie ist Battlefield mir jetzt
ein bisschen zu langweilig, weil ich nicht
mehr weiß, was ich noch tun soll. Das stimmt schon.
Das ist meine Sorge, dass das passieren könnte. Und wenn dann
die Leute abspringen, da muss dann die
erste Season echt knallen.
Nee, Halo habe ich noch nicht gespielt.
Ich habe es mir seit zwei Tagen runtergeladen
und will es endlich mal ausprobieren. Ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht auf die Reihe
gekriegt.
Das ist ja auch was, also, auch da
ich spekuliere, aber man sieht dem Spiel
ja an, dass sie nicht fertig geworden sind.
Ja, korrekt. Also das kann natürlich auch an der
Pandemie liegen. Ich habe da
viel Verständnis für, dass Spielentwicklung gerade schwierig
ist. Ja, da hat er recht. Aber ich habe
im Video gesagt, ich bin nicht der Meinung, dass man es auf Corona
verschieben kann. Also das Spiel wurde ja
zum größten Teil während Corona
entwickelt. Da hätte man sich darauf einstellen können.
Dafür sind Projektleiter da. Und andere
Hersteller haben auch gezeigt, dass man in der Zeit
Spiele entwickeln kann.
Aber sie sind ja
mit Battlefield nicht fertig geworden. Das heißt,
sie starten, glaube ich, jetzt schon mit einem
massiven Zeitnachteil.
Weil sie den ganzen Kram reinkriegen müssen.
So kann man das sehen, ja. Die Launchversion
muss überhaupt erst an den Punkt
1.0 gebracht werden, dass sie halt funktioniert.
Interne Versionsnummer von Battlefield
ist übrigens 0.2.1. Nicht, dass Versionsnummern
irgendwas zu sagen haben. Spätestens seit
Chrome Version 274
und Firefox 98 und so was.
Aber ich finde es schon irgendwie
witzig in Funfact. Der Content kommen
ab Januar. Der muss halt gut sein. Der muss
regelmäßig kommen. Da muss eigentlich alle 2, 3,
4 Wochen ein Patch da sein. Die bräuchten den
IT-Projektleiter vom letzten Video genau.
Ist viel vorgenommen. Wir müssen ein paar
Coding-Cutters machen. Ich hoffe, dass sie es hinbekommen.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher. Es wird jetzt aber
auch gefragt von Halfblade.
Was haltet ihr von
dem Review-Bombing
in der ersten Woche?
Review hilft halt dann, wenn es dich auch irgendwie
aufklärt über Stärken und Schwächen.
Wenn es irgendwo fair und ausgeglichen ist.
Enttäuschung verstehe ich.
Mit Hass gegen ein Spiel tue ich mich
immer schwer. Und sehr oft gehen halt diese
Review-Bombings in eine
zu starke Richtung. Aber natürlich,
dass Leute uns... Das Spiel hat bei der GameStar
71% bekommen. Das ist für die
GameStar richtig schlecht.
Gerade für Battlefield. Also 71%
ist eigentlich in GameStar
Maßstab. Ich meine, die haben theoretisch von 0 bis 100.
Aber man kann quasi sagen,
alles unter 70 bei der GameStar
ist hypertrash. Und
alles unter 80 ist meistens
nicht spielenswert.
Auf Reddit
gerade sehr harsh auch über die Probleme
diskutiert wird. Also Reddit ist gerade voll
mit halt
negativen Threats, die ganzen
Probleme darstellen.
Das muss man natürlich schon ernst nehmen.
Ich hab Hans noch nie gespielt.
Auf Reddit sind gerade sehr viele leidenschaftliche Menschen unterwegs,
die sich viel Mühe geben,
in riesigen Threats die ganzen Probleme aufzuzeigen,
Gameplay festzuhalten, um den Entwicklern
irgendwie zu helfen.
Dice kommentiert das auch. Sie sehen auch die Probleme.
Es ist nicht so, als wären sie jetzt komplett stumm.
Siehst du denn unter all den Problemen
noch ein richtig gutes und
rettenswertes Spiel?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist da. Und das macht es so tragisch.
Gut, da sind für
anderer Meinung, ich sehe
den guten Kern nicht.
Ja, es hat seine Momente,
aber es hat so viel
unfertigen Kram,
undurchdachten Kram.
RPI Cloud,
Dankeschön für den Raid, Poggers.
Was ist denn heute mit den
Raids los, meine Güte hier?
Jetzt gerade, wo ich mir fremden Content
angucke, werden hier die ganze Zeit
geradet.
Danke für den Raid.
...
und man irgendwo in einen Punkt
reinkommt und ihn zusammen mit drei
Squadmates halt dann hält gegen eine absolute
Übermacht, weil man sich irgendwie gut abspricht,
weil man das Gadget gut nutzt. Und wenn man mit Leuten
unterwegs ist, die auch, obwohl das Spiel das
jetzt leider nicht mehr so wirklich motivierend macht,
aber die halt irgendwie Medic spielen und Versorger spielen,
und man sich wirklich in so einen Punkt
reinzackt und die sich da nicht mehr raus
kriegen lässt. Also die Sachen, die auch schon in Battle 4
und in Battle 5... Ja, da hat er recht, das sind
wirklich die Momente von dem Spiel. Aber
wisst ihr, dass, also warum ich
halt den guten, also den, den,
den guten Kern in diesem Spiel
nicht sehe, ist, dass die
Dinger, die noch
halbwegs gut sind und funktionieren,
die sind, wo sie nicht dran rumgeschraubt
haben.
Das heißt, das ist nicht
irgendwie Battlefield 2042,
was den, was
das Game irgendwie rettet im Kern.
Das ist die Dinger, die halt Battlefield
sind und noch quasi
nicht verschlimmbessert wurden. Das sind die,
die das Game gut machen. Deswegen
sehe ich persönlich da keinen guten Kern drin, aber
kann mir ne geteilter Meinung sein.
Dann macht das Spaß.
Und dass das herauszukitzeln...
Hey, zu diesem, zu meinem Sponsored-Video muss ich sagen,
ja klar, erstens, ja,
Big Stonks Money, aber
ich habe diese
Sponsoring unterschrieben,
bevor ich wusste, dass das Game
so kacke ist.
Dann hätte ich das nicht gemacht, hätte ich das gewusst.
Ich weiß noch, ich habe dem, ich habe
dem geantwortet per Mail, habe ich
ihm geschrieben, also ich mach, klar,
warum nicht, ich mach ja wahrscheinlich eh massig Videos zu.
Ich muss nicht sagen,
dass es gut ist, naja gut, ich muss,
die Videos mussten abgenommen werden. Ich kann das nicht sagen,
hier gucken wir uns erstmal die
5000-seitige Buckliste an.
...möglich ist zu erleben.
Das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe, die DICE da jetzt hat.
Das ist nach wie vor drin.
Es wird nur einfach,
wenn du jetzt Battlefield spielst,
merkst du einfach, dieses Spiel blockiert
die ganze Zeit den Weg zu diesem
Gameplay-Spaß. Dadurch, dass alle
mit Waffen spielen, die stärker sind, als das,
was du jetzt ausprobieren willst. Dadurch, dass du,
dass halt niemand dich revived, weil niemand
Medics spielt, weil dieses Specialist-System
das nicht mehr motivierend macht, Medics
zu spielen. Dadurch, dass halt auch irgendwie du
aus einer Session rausfliegst, das Spiel ruckelt bei dir,
es halt Performance-Schwankungen gibt, je nachdem,
wie das Wetter ist auf der Karte. Dadurch,
dass du halt, wenn deine Freundesrunde zu groß
ist, dass ihr nicht zusammen auf demselben Server spielen könnt.
Das klingt jetzt nach einer keinem großen... Alter, wie da die Bots
gebashed werden. Das nervt doch, wenn du fünf Leute da
hast und ihr könnt nicht zusammen spielen.
Das ist halt so ein basic Ding.
Und dann muss man sich irgendeinen Battlefield-Portal-Server
suchen und dann zusammen
auf der Serverliste absuchen.
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben, da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Dann hat man auch irgendwie Verbindungsprobleme
oder landet in gegnerischen Teams, weil man irgendwie,
weil das Matchmaking das nicht gut macht.
Das ist einfach blöd. Das ist einfach nicht cool.
Es wird noch von Red Puma gefragt,
findet ihr 128 Spiele,
ist es ein echtes Killer-Feature oder hättet ihr lieber
kleine, aber feiner gehabt? Da sind wir
unterschiedlicher Meinung. Wir hatten heute
just einen Podcast mit Fabian Siegesmund
und... Tja, meine Meinung ist,
128 Spieler hat dem Spiel nicht
gut getan. Man kann sicherlich
128 Spieler machen,
aber dann nicht auf so glanlos
offenen Maps. Wenn die Maps mehr wie
Manifest mit den Container Areas wären,
vielleicht, wenn das Ganze gerade in
Breakthrough ein bisschen auseinander gezogener
wäre, vielleicht.
Es gab aber ja auch schon Tests in den vergangenen
Battlefields, dass 128 Spieler nicht richtig
funktioniert haben. Man konnte bei
Venice sehen, dass 128 Spieler
in Battlefield 3, auch auf den
großen Maps,
naja, auch nicht das Gelbe
vom Aiwahn. Also es liegt nicht nur
in Battlefield 2042 und
es ist halt,
wie ich auch im Video gesagt habe,
es ist noch nicht mal Masse statt Klasse.
Es ist jetzt halt
einfach nicht
zu Ende gedacht.
Der Kollege Phil Elzner, der ja auch unser
Battlefield-Experte ist bei der GameStar,
zu Battlefield, der kommt glaube ich am
Samstag, also hört den Podcast, der ist cool.
Die beiden sind der Meinung, dass die 128
Spieler zu viel sind.
Ich auch.
Aber richtig,
Breakthrough ist für'n Arsch.
Und gerade Phil
ist da der Meinung, dass es einfach zu sehr
ein Marketing Gimmick ist, dass man
128 auf die Packung schreiben kann,
um irgendeine Form von Next-Gen-Feature
zu machen.
Nee, ist Schwachsinn.
Ich meine, auf die Idee kommt ja jeder, der halbwegs
nicht durch seine rosarote Fanboy-Brille guckt.
Manado, der, wie ich schon oft genug gesagt habe,
ein in meinen Augen blödes Feature ist.
Also ich hab noch nicht so super negative
Erfahrungen damit gemacht. Ich finde gerade bei
Conquest mag ich das eigentlich, dass es
wenig Leerlauf gibt. Und ich bin auch der Meinung,
dass man Kontrollpunkte
immer noch gut erobern kann, wenn man sich halt
die rauspickt, die jetzt nicht so überlaufen sind.
Das sehe ich anders,
wenn du zu einer Flagge gehst
in Conquest. Du machst einen Flank,
das dauert schon drei, vier Minuten,
und dann spawnen 40 Leute bei dir in der Flagge rein,
weil die sehen hoch, die Flagge geht ja runter.
Und dann bist du auf einmal mit eins, zwei, drei
Leuten dagegen irgendwie
mehr als früher in eine ganze Battlefield-Partie
reingepasst haben.
Und das finde ich nicht gut. Also ich bin auch
der Mann 128-Spieler. Nope.
Aber ich glaube, das hängt auch von den
Erfahrungen ab, die man auf dem Schlachtfeld
macht, wenn halt dauernd Matches
in totalem Knubbel enden.
Es gibt auch diese Choke Points auf den Karten.
Ich glaube, wie heißt das denn? Renewal.
Das ist so eine Map, wo die eine Hälfte wütet,
und die andere Hälfte so ein
aquaculture-grünes
Agrargebiet.
Und da gibt es eine Mauer dazwischen.
Und diese Mauer hat halt einen Durchgang,
wo halt dann alle durchwinden. Die Mauer hat
an den Seiten, aber das
ist unsinnig. Aber da musst du
weit hin rennen, und du wirst dann eh komplett
weggemacht, wenn du da alleine durchläufst.
Das heißt, es knubbelt sich sehr an einem Choke Point
in dieser Map. Das sehe ich,
was mich halt nerven kann.
Es gab noch eine Frage zur allgemeinen
Strategie des Spiels, was ich auch durchaus
spannend finde. Ist Battlefield der Versuch
von EA, Warzone zu kopieren,
eine Plattform für drei oder mehr Spiele
in einem?
Es ist nicht der Versuch, Warzone zu kopieren.
Es war der Versuch, Warzone zu kopieren.
Und man hat festgestellt, es wird nichts.
Und hat deswegen Battlefield draus gemacht.
Dass sie Warzone kriegen können,
haben sie in dem Moment verspielt, in dem sie
Hazard Zone nicht kostenlos gemacht haben.
Ja, so ist es.
So ist es.
Genau so ist es.
Was halt sein kann, ist, dass sie
Portal langfristig ausbauen
zu so einer spieleübergreifenden
Plattform.
Da muss ich aber auch noch einiges tun.
Das ist hier auf der Falle.
Es kann sein, dass sie Portal ausbauen
zu so einer spieleübergreifenden Plattform,
dass du halt da plötzlich Battlefield 1 drin hast,
Battlefield 4 drin hast, Battlefield 5 drin hast.
Das ist halt
natürlich sehr viel Zukunftsmusik.
Aktuell sind da ja nur drei Spiele drin,
mit jeweils zwei Karten.
Aber es kann sein, dass es langfristig
größer wird.
Ich glaube nur, zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt hat Battlefield keine Chance,
Warzone den Rang abzulaufen.
Ich finde das interessant, dass das alles
in eine ähnliche Richtung geht.
Ich meine, der hat das jetzt natürlich deutlich diplomatischer
als ich in meinem Video ausgedrückt.
Ich war da etwas emotionaler
aufgeladen. Aber es ist witzig, dass alle,
die schon ein bisschen länger dabei sind,
oder viele, alle kann man immer nicht sagen,
aber dass viele, die auch schon ein bisschen länger dabei sind
und die, die es nicht
gar so sehr durch die Fanboybrille sehen wollen,
zu, sagen wir mal so zu,
den größten Punkten eigentlich
zu ähnlichen Schlussfolgerungen kommen.
Spielt es sich auch irgendwie wie
alten Battlefields in Portal 9? Nein, leider nicht.
Die Portal-Implementierung
von Bad Company 2
und Battlefield 3 hat mit den
Original-Spielen eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Außer, dass es die Maps gibt
und dass es
die Waffen im Endeffekt vergibt von damals.
Aber das Handling ist komplett anders.
Das Gameplay ist komplett anders.
Das Movement ist komplett anders.
Das Spielgefühl ist komplett anders. Also,
Battlefield 3 in BC 2 hat überhaupt nichts mit den
Vorgaben zu tun.
Deswegen verstehe ich die
große
ja, Freude
über Portal noch nicht. Man kann mit Portal
viel machen. Ich habe ja auch ein Video zu gemacht
zu Portal,
wo ich gezeigt habe, wie man zum Beispiel
Nosha Canals TDM
bauen kann. Na, das wird dann schon ein bisschen
umfangreicher hier in Portal, wo man das machen
muss. Und da
kann man einige coole Sachen damit machen, aber
man hat wenig Einfluss auf das eigentliche Spiel.
Also, man kann zum Beispiel
nicht sagen, wir machen Nosha Canals TDM
und
mit Battlefield 3 Soldaten, aber
Gadgets aus Battlefield 2042,
was sehr cool gewesen wäre
für diese Geschichte hier.
Und man kann keine
Map-Begrenzung setzen zum Beispiel.
Man kann an den Fahrzeugen nichts ändern, man kann
die Fahrzeuge zwar ausschalten, aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen,
hey, ich mache weniger Fahrzeuge
oder ich spawne mal ein Fahrzeug
irgendwo auf der Map und sowas.
Also sprich, die
Möglichkeiten in Portal sind sehr begrenzt. Das,
was ich hier gemacht habe in dem Video, ist fast
schon das Maximale, was man so
aus Portal rausholen kann.
Wie weit sind die Transpiler für Portal?
Weiß ich nicht, ich muss mal im Discord gucken.
Falls er daran weitergemacht hat, keine Ahnung.
Das hier schon gesehen?
Nö.
Das ist ja witzig.
Ja, ich weiß auch sofort, wie er es gemacht hat.
Das Einzige, was du machen kannst,
ist, um die Position
von irgendwas zu bestimmen, du kannst
Spieler teleportieren und das macht er mit den Bots.
Das geht leider nicht für Fahrzeuge
oder sonstige Sachen.
Aber das ist schon cool.
Das ist schon cool.
Da sieht man mal, was mit kreativen
Ideen und eingeschränkten Möglichkeiten möglich ist.
Was ich noch nicht so ganz verstehe,
ist, wie er es geschafft hat,
zu erkennen,
dass der Spieler jetzt
da durchfliegt.
Es könnte sein, dass er das anhand
des Waffenwechsels der Bots
erkennt eventuell.
das müsste ich das muss mal gucken das finde ich interessant wie er die
position bestimmt dass der jetzt durch den ring geflogen ist
na gut oder oder er fragt er fragt die posis spieler position ab das geht ja
auch
aber cool ist das finde ich schon finde ich richtig gut gemacht
das ist schon geil
das ist schon echt gut
wenn das cool die man die möglichkeiten sind wirklich ziemlich beschränkt in
portal aber man sieht was man was man rausholen kann mit mit hirn
das ist echt cool
also den modus würde ich tatsächlich gern sogar mal ausprobieren das ist
richtig cool gemacht mit hirn ist alles einfacher
das stimmt deswegen für jeden primes ab wisst ihr ja ein IQ punkt für jeden
mit hirn ist alles einfacher so sieht es aus und so einfach wie hier hat man
noch nie hirn bekommen so was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an
kannst du das spielen jetzt ich habe gar nicht geguckt ob der code dabei
steht steht da kaut dabei kein kauter bei
also wenn ein kauter bei steht dann haben wir das spiel hallo youtube
please laden
es steht kein kauter bei dann kann man es nicht spielen
ist eine tower defense variante machbar
das stelle ich mir schwierig vor du kannst die maps halt nicht anpassen
das heißt du müsstest irgendwie eine möglichkeit finden die bots an
vorgefertigten wegen laufen zu lassen das heißt du müsstest quasi permanent
bots hardcoded positions zuweisen ich glaube dass das eher im bereich des
theoretisch möglichen ist aber praktisch mit portal nicht umsetzbar
danke für die subs hier kressa und in exo
also ich glaube praktisch möglich ist eine tower defense geschichte nicht du
kannst die maps nicht ändern bot bewegung halt durch schwer und die maps
sind also auf den tower defense würde ja bedeuten du hast eher so ein korridor
wurde das dann die fände also ich wüsste jetzt nicht wie das gehen soll
weil ich das so mache das habe ich mir so angewöhnt es ergibt keinen tieferen
sinn ist so so was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an
du kannst keine maps begrenzen es sei denn das geht jetzt also wenn das geht
wäre richtig geil weil dann könnte man gute 64 spieler maps machen
ach so du meinst dass du die passenden maps nimmst ja aber trotzdem selbst
noch schaar kennels eignet sich nicht für tower defense auf noch schaar kennels
hast ja von einer seite zur anderen auch zwanzig verschiedene wege aber du kannst
die maps nicht begrenzen zumindest habe ich nichts dazu gefunden es
wird mich sehr wundern wenn das geht du kannst nicht einfach
nee du kannst nicht einfach eine vorgefertigte map nehmen und die map
aus zone ändern das haben die gesagt dass das möglich sein wird aber ich
habe davon nichts gesehen also wenn das nicht super versteckt ist irgendwo dann
dann geht das nicht es wäre cool wenn es geht weil dann
wäre einiges mehr möglich
geht nicht hätte mich auch gewundert wenn das geht ich habe es nämlich
nirgendwo gefunden so schauen wir uns jetzt als nächstes an
der 0 euro pc von ebay na gut noch ein bellfilm müssen wir uns jetzt nicht
angucken was passiert wenn die erneut das gucken
wir uns nachher noch mal gespannt der 0 euro pc von ebay irgendwas stimmt
nicht das ist ist es wieder so ein video wo der typ sich selbst ein pc
hingestellt hat und sagt dass das jetzt ein pc angeblich von ebay wäre oder ist
es legit weiß nicht wahrscheinlich ist es legit
kenne ich nicht aber ich will den leuten ja nichts unterstellen aber bei manchen
dieser videos habe ich immer den eindruck die sind krass gefaked
schauen wir mal der 0 euro aber irgendwas stimmt nicht
der ist viel zu sauber für den 0 euro pc von ebay die 0 euro dinger die man bei
ebay kleiner zeigen findet die sind keine ahnung oftmals so so gelb wie okay ich
will es nicht eklig ist als vergleich bringen aber die sind ziemlich gelb ja
und eklig oftmals und eingestaubt es gibt bestimmt bei ebay kleiner zeigen
immer noch leute die auch bei 0 euro fragen was letzte preis kann ich mir
richtig vorstellen hier zum abholen 0 euro was letzte preis legst du noch was
drauf wenn ich mitnehme was du minus preis gibst du mir noch oder
irgendwas ja leute und willkommen zu einem video auf dem timos hardwares
kanal ja heute wieder ein anderer kulisse ich hoffe dass es für euch
trotzdem ok weil es ist nicht ok video beendet angenehmer hier mein zimmer
anzeige ist raus heute geht es um diesen pc hier den habe ich für 0 euro auf
ebay kleiner zeigen geschenkt bekommen im rahmen des letzten projektes auch noch
allerdings habe ich das jetzt erst ein extra video gepackt weil ich das halt
nach ende des letzten videos erst zeigt ein youtube noch downwards an ja weil ich
glück habe und wir werden uns heute mal anschauen ob dieser rechner den noch
funktioniert was da verbaut ist und was das teil noch kann weil ich habe gar
keine ahnung und ich bin auch sehr gespannt bei einem blick auf die
vorderseite des rechners sehen wir schon wir haben zweimal usb 2
klinkensteckeranschlüsse ein resetknopf ein power button und das war es auch
schon und laut dem internau sollte da tatsächlich keine korte reiche auch was
brauchsten vorne mehr am rechner ist das auch für den disketten laufwerk da
unten heute könnte das noch für disketten laufwerk sein
ich überlege gerade was der letzte rechner war der noch in disketten laufwerk
hatte das ist schon noch mal locker 20 jahr her
und dann wahrscheinlich eher aber das werden wir auch mal sehen der pc war
übrigens auch sehr sehr leicht also das gehäuse ist wirklich relativ bildlich
sieht aber ganz ordentlich aus sieht aber aus wie so 3,5 zoll also da kann man
auch das laufwerk dran machen da haben wir ganz normales ps2
oh yes exquisite ps2 tastatur und maus so muss es sein
kein dvi nur vga gut das ist das ist schon ein bisschen in die jahre gekommen
das ding würde ich sagen aber mit original dell windows 8
windows 8 7 pro steht da windows steht da wirklich windows 8 7 pro
was soll denn das sein
wann meinst du kommt der battlefield 2042 ende nächster woche aber ich weiß
nicht was du mit der patch meinst der nächste kommt wahrscheinlich ende
nächster woche
aber ob der großartig was fixen wird werden wir mal gucken
plus würde ich mal sagen bei meinem schwarzes netzteil also ein
kaltgerätesteckeranschluss 2 x ps2 kein dvi einmal vga 2 x usb 3 0 2 x usb 2 0
ein etat das ist das eher ok es ist im prinzip und reichlich immerhin immerhin
schon usb 3 eine grafikkarte oder sonstige extension karte nicht verbaut
ach und hier ist übrigens noch ein windows 7 lizenz auf kliber also beim
screenshot falls irgendwer den brauch oder sich dafür interessiert hier habt
ihr ihn den rechner und gucken ob er noch geht das aufmachen des rechners ist
ziemlich einfach der hat einfach zwei schrauben die man auch mit der hand
aufmachen kann und das panel zu entfernen war sehr sehr einfach und wie man hier
drin auch schon erkennen kann der rechner scheint noch vollständig zu sein
never sub never donated neighbors wifi free entertainment free windows key es
hat sich auf jeden fall ein bisschen staub angesammelt besonders beim lüfter
aber das ist gar nicht so schlimm das können wir das sieht doch relativ gute
alte bios da braunes mainboard jawoll dass der rechner stammt noch aus zeiten
da waren mainboards entweder braun grün oder blau nicht irgendwie wie heute
schwarz mit silber leiter platten und und wärme heat spreader und so mit gute
alte hardware farbe von früher
wir auch ganz einfach sauber machen wir haben ein ram regel verbaut und eine
festplatte ist tatsächlich auch noch drin also wie gesagt vollständig ist auf
jeden fall ich würde mal sagen bevor ich jetzt da irgendwas großartig am
rechner tue und den auseinander baue werde ich jetzt erst mal den rechner
testen dafür werde ich ein kleines setup aufbauen und wir sehen uns gleich
wieder so da ist das setup und ich werde den rechner einfach mal an machen und
hoffen dass er funktioniert und ja wie man sieht das er funktioniert und der
rechner auch und der sah aber auch ja so gut aus hätte mich gewundert wenn er
nicht mehr angeht kommt auch also das sieht schon mal sehr sehr gut
wichtig wichtig die rgb tastatur sonst ist fraglich ob der rechner geboten
hätte aber ich glaube die rgb tastatur als rausgerissen
vor allem der performance boost macht halt aus 7 logo das heißt die festplatte
wurde auf jeden fall nicht formatiert und ja hier sind wir tatsächlich auch
schon bei der benutzerkonten auswahl ich habe das gar jetzt mal hier
warum löschen die leute ihre sachen nicht ich verstehe es einfach nicht ich
verstehe es nicht wie kann man so blöd sein sein alten rechner verschenken ohne
und die daten alle drauf lassen ich verstehe es einfach nicht
übrigens das ist ein weiterer punkt für einfach jede festplatte voll
verschlüsseln du musst dir um so was keine gedanken mehr machen geht ja gar
nicht darum wenn das fbi vor der tür steht sondern es ist einfach auch viel
angenehmer man muss sich um nichts gedanken machen
man kann die festplatte nehmen auf den müll schmeißen und niemand kommt mehr an
die daten dran wieder weil es halt private daten sind und da namen stehen
allerdings war an dem einen kein password drin deswegen habe ich mir
erlaubt da reinzugehen um zu schauen was der rechner für komponenten hat und ja
bei den eigenschaften sieht man auch schon wir haben verbaut und das war auch
schon meine befürchtung ein zellern vermutung es ist verbaut oje zellern g
moment ist das ein single core ist das ein single core zellern
2,7 single core das ist das ist pence champ 1820 mit 2,7 gigahertz das ist ein
sehr sehr na wie soll ich sagen der der schlechteste bzw billigste zellern aus
der ruma dann anscheinend 2 cores nein es ist ein es ist ein immerhin du aber
trotzdem aber trotzdem richtig mies also das ist wirklich ein sehr sehr budget
office pc würde ich mal sagen ebenfalls in 4 gigabyte also also wenn das der
admin pc es würde mich auch mal interessieren ob da vielleicht spannende
dinger drauf sind oder ist es der default die das der
default benutzernahme der default benutzernahme ist der 3 in dem fall und
es ist ein 64 bildbetriebssystem was mich ein bisschen wundert ist dieses
ganze dell zeug da war auch schon der lizenz aufkleber hersteller dell also ich
weiß nicht genau wie das teil aufgesetzt wurde aber interessant ist es auf jeden
fall ja aber jetzt wo ich weiß dass ich weiß wie das aufgesetzt wurde das
wurde mit diesem fake fake dell activator aktiviert wahrscheinlich
falls das noch jemand kennt ich will jetzt den namen nicht sagen aber wenn
noch sieben benutzt hat und sich da beschäftigt hat was da so geht in der
richtung dem wird es schon öfters aufgefallen sein werde ich ihn wieder
ausmachen und ich werde mal auseinander bauen die einzelnen komponenten einmal
es gab so ein boot also für all dies nicht wissen es gab so einen bootloader patch für
winnows sieben die unter anderem dell zertifikate injected haben so dass der
rechner gedacht hat er ist ein dell dell hardware und aktiviert sich
automatisch und sowas auch reinigen bevor wir wieder zusammenbauen vielleicht
habe ich auch ein cpu upgrade was ich bei dem rechner mal durchführen will jetzt
aber noch mal kurz ein blick ins bios hier sehen wir auch noch mal das
mainboard und zwar handelt es sich um einen bio star h81 c mhs habe ich auch
das gehört ob wir es natürlich ganz klar dass das weltbekannte mein bio star
h81 c mhs habe ich auch noch nie von gehört gehört auch glaube ich eher zu
der budget reihe allgemein bio star ist jetzt nicht die mainboard mark an die
man vielleicht erstmal denkt und die festplatte nach kurzem googeln hat sich
ergeben es ist eine toshiba 500 gigabyte fest immerhin noch ein dvd brenner so
ich habe den pc jetzt hier mal auf den tisch getan und ich werde jetzt einfach
mal beginnen das ganze einfach rauszubauen und sauber zu machen und als
erstes habe ich hier alle kabel entfernt und das ist ziemlich dumm gemacht bei
einem sata kabel unten das kriegt man kaum ab weil er direkt der ram slot
daneben ist aber mit ein bisschen hilfe habe ich rausbekommen und dann
natürlich noch die schrauben lösen des mainboards und nach einer zeit kann man
das dann schon einfach rausnehmen was ich probiert hätte ich hatte mir
gar nicht die arbeit gemacht aber es wird so auf seine art wahrscheinlich
sauberer ich hätte mir wahrscheinlich entweder den sauger geholt und gesaugt
oder in kombination mit irgend so einem luftdruck puste ding es gibt ja so
dosen mit druckluft da kannst du einfach alles ab pusten oder wer so was als
gerät hat ist natürlich noch besser einfach mal einfach mal reingepustet und
gesaugt fertig und den rest hätte ich wahrscheinlich einfach so gelassen
was willst du mit dem rechner machen es hat ja noch nicht mal es hat ja nicht
mal sinn also selbst wenn du den jetzt super super krass
glänzend machst also du kannst ja damit nichts anfangen und verkaufen kannst
ihn auch nicht so hier seht ihr einmal das mainboard es ist doch gar nicht so
dreckig wie ich dachte der dreck ist nur beim cpu lüfter hier sind einmal die
ports und es ist ein vier gigabyte riegel von crucial verbaut und was ich
sehr interessant finde bei dem dvi port ist das irgendwie ein heißkleber
heißkleber festgeklebt diese eine blende damit man auch ja nicht ein kabel
irgendwo reinsteckt wo sowieso kein port gibt als nächstes war die festplatte
dran dazu waren einfach zwei schrauben zu lösen auf der rückseite war
tatsächlich auch noch eine aber aber kein selbst für den pylon rechner das
ding braucht ja wahrscheinlich auch noch eitel mehr strom als was aktuelles auch
wenn die zeleron sachen relativ sparsam waren aber das ist von das ding ist von
2007 oder so keine ahnung von wann die cpu ist und der rechner die kisten haben
damals eitel wahrscheinlich 40 watt gebraucht oder so trotz zeleron gut
rausnehmen das ist wie gesagt eine tauschina interessiert vielleicht macht
er noch vielleicht hängt das mal irgendwo dran dass wir sehen was ist was
es verbraucht dazu einfach auch hier die zwei schrauben rausschrauben auf der
rückseite war auch wieder eine und dann natürlich noch das netzteil und das
werde ich wahrscheinlich auch tauschen weil sie brauche komische fiepen wenn
der rechner aus ist ist das nee das ist ist das ein lc power man erkennt nicht
lc power ist die ist die china china chinesen mocha smoke netzteil hersteller
einzige netzteil was mir jemals verreckt ist bei einer gesamten it laufbahn ich
weiß nicht wie es nennen soll war lc power ziemlich ziemlich nervig wenn er
an ist dann hört man das gar nicht so aber wenn er aus ist nervt es wirklich
einfach aufpülen mit heißkleber da kann es auch nicht mal quitschen jetzt sind
hier mal alle komponenten auf dem tisch und ich werde mich jetzt erstmal dem
mainboard widmen das werde ich sauber machen und das ist artika was für einen
netzteil hersteller ist das ATK netzteil
ach nee ATX netzteil ah ich kann ja vielleicht ist es doch lc power das
werde ich sauber machen und auch die cpu austauschen und welche ich da nehme
werde ich euch gleich zeigen nach abnehmen des cpu kühlers sieht man dass
ich doch schon ziemlich viel dreck angesammelt hat und beim wegmachen der
wärmeleitpaste kommt der seleron hervor da ist er so und diesen seleron werde ich
tauschen mit einem hallo seleron 1160 das ist tatsächlich auch der einzige
dann kann man sogar mit dem rechner wieder halbwegs was anfangen den ich für
den sockel noch rum liegen habe ist natürlich auch nicht der beste aber ein
upgrade ist es allemal das mainboard an sich war jetzt nicht wirklich dreckig
habe ich einfach aber warum also ich frage mich was macht ihr denn damit also
du kannst ja damit trotzdem nichts anfangen den cpu luft habe ich einfach
mit druckluft so genau 10 sekunden war er auch sehr sauber wie man hier mal kurz
sieht also die neue cpu abgeblasen wärmeleitpaste drauf und dann natürlich
den kühler zu guter letzt kommt natürlich noch der ram rein den werde
ich jetzt nicht upgraden aber 8 gigabyte sind auf jeden fall empfohlen würde ich
mal sagen als ersatz netzteil werde ich dieses h.e.c. 400 watt netz z.b.
ich weiß das sieht optisch nicht wirklich gut das sieht nach 9m schiener
böller aus aber wahrscheinlich geht es trotzdem im vergleich zu dem anderen aber
es funktioniert zumindest einwandfrei und fiept nicht irgendwie nervig die
festplatte und das laufwerk werde ich einfach so lassen das muss ich auch nicht
wirklich sauber machen weil es schon ziemlich sauber ist aber das gehäuse ist
natürlich noch da und das ist schon etwas dreckig unten und das habe ich
dann einfach mal rausgetragen um das bisschen sauber zu machen weil ich wollte
staub halte ich in meinem zimmer haben und das ganze sieht jetzt auch schon
wieder sehr gut gute taktik sagen ich baue den pc mal zusammen dafür natürlich
erst mal wieder das netzteil rein da noch das mainboard und ich will euch
den ganzen platz ich habe letztens ein video gesehen da ist einer hier mit dem
akkuschrauber ran zusammen dafür natürlich ich mein geht bestimmt mit
akkuschrauber aber irgendwie ist mir das fein feinfühliger mit dem schraubenzieher
oder schraubendreher bevor wieder bei leute gedrehert sind mir das lieber als
dem akkuschrauber ran ich erst mal wieder das netzteil rein da noch das
mainboard und ich will euch den ganzen prozess jetzt mal ersparen und ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns wieder wenn ich den pc zusammengebaut habe ich
habe mich halt immer noch was damit jetzt rauskommen soll am ende ist jetzt keine
eins plus aber letztendlich sieht man es auch nicht besser aus als mein rechner
und ja ich werde mein kleines test da wieder aufbauen und ich hoffe einfach
mal dass der angeht weil wer doof wenn nicht und ja beim anmachen zeigt sich
auch der rechner geht tatsächlich wieder an das hat mich auch sehr gefreut und wie
man hier auch sieht cpu has changed das aber normal weil die cpu halt auch
gewechselt er geht an ich habe natürlich dann wieder erst mal ins bios geguckt und
dann wollte ich windows installieren über ein usb oder gemacht habe es muss
nicht mehr änderung sein sobald ich auf save
warum zeigt er kein signal
so knallgeräusche sind meistens nicht das ist merkwürdig was ist denn was ist
denn da los ja und einmal kurz zu beschreiben was genau hier mein problem
war ganz einfach sobald ich irgendwelche änderungen bei ausgemacht habe oder es
muss nicht mehr änderung sein sobald ich auf save und exit gedrückt habe um den
pc neu zu starten ist der pc zwar angeblieben aber alles ist ausgegangen
und ich habe mir die piste aufgeschrieben und ich habe die piste
aufgeschrieben und ich habe die piste aufgeschrieben und ich habe die piste
neu zu starten ist der pc zwar angeblieben aber alles ist ausgegangen
monitor tastatur maus die batterie leer den reset knopf drücken nicht dass es
irgendwas mit der batterie zu tun haben könnte in der theorie aber das ist
das einzige was mir einfällt das einzige was geholfen war tatsächlich entweder
stecker ziehen oder den netzzeitschalter umlegen das hat mich echt gewundert und
ich konnte mir nicht erklären woran das lag ich habe einige optionen bei aus noch
angepasst aber das hat nichts geholfen also ich weiß es wirklich nicht
ich konnte windows dennoch installieren hat natürlich ein bisschen länger
gedauert weil immer wenn er neu gestartet hat musste ich dann das ist ja
fehl wieder anmachen damit ich mit der installation konnte letztendlich hat es
aber funktioniert und ja wir sind hier natürlich auch in windows 10 drin in
windows funktioniert doch alles gut bei jedem ribut stecker raus reicht das
eigentlich noch als office pc aus man kann ja man kann sachen schreiben man
kann sachen die cpu auslastung zeigen soll die sie ist bestimmt bei youtube auf
90 prozent 480p wenn es aber etwas anspruchsvoller sein soll dann würde ich
definitiv den ram upgraden gegebenenfalls eine ssd einbauen und vielleicht auch
eine grafik also ich würde mir gegebenenfalls besseren rechner kaufen
grafisch aufwändigere programme benutzt werden dennoch hatte der pc jetzt immer
noch den gleichen fehler mit dem neustart auch in windows sprich wenn man
auf neustarten drückt passiert gar nichts der bildschirm geht einfach aus
der rechner bleibt an resetknopf funktioniert nicht und auf button
funktioniert nicht nur strom aus und angeht ich kann es mir wirklich nicht
erklären falls irgendjemand von euch da eine ahnung hat lasst es mich gerne in
den kommentaren wissen eine weitere sache die mir aufgefallen ist die ich
ehrlich gesagt ganz witzig finde ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt irgendwelche
schlimmeren hintergründe hat ist dass man die systemplatte also da wo
wunders drauf installiert ist unten bei den geräten einfach auswerfen ich weiß
nicht was es damit auf sich hat das windows logik windows logik funktioniert
zwar nicht dennoch finde ich irgendwie witzig dass es da überhaupt angezeigt
wird so das war es jetzt hier noch einmal der rechner wie gesagt den kann
man auf jeden fall noch für offiz sachen nutzen und jetzt kommt er nach dem video
auf den müll er hat seine schuldigkeit getan und weg damit auf jeden fall noch
upgraden was macht er damit jetzt die festplatte und vielleicht kommen bei der
grafikkarte und beim raum auch noch was machen wie gesagt wenn man nicht auf
neustarten drückt dann kann man den rechner ganz normal nutzen weil beim
runterfahren geht auch aus nur beim neustarten nicht aber das problem ist so
kann ich ihn leider jetzt auch nicht an irgendwem geben oder verkaufen weil
erst gern beheben aber ansonsten funktioniert der rechner außerhalb des
fehlers einwandfrei ja das war es mit dem video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn ja dann lasst doch gerne bewertung da das grenzt ja an körperverletzungen
wenn man jemand so eine so einen rechner benutzen lässt er
subscriber giveaway sehr gute idee das zieht immer aber ob die leute die da auf
youtube gucken das wirklich haben wollen aber wobei freestuff freestuff sind die
leute nicht wählerisch ja das habe ich auch gedacht aber ich glaube nicht dass
es da was hilft
ok was gucken wir uns bei youtube noch mal die chance geben
oder ich krieg hunger aber wir gucken noch ein bisschen was aber ich ich krieg
hunger pippo fett heim
den gucken wir nicht der empfiehlt nämlich bestimmt wieder den moment das
video wurde mir von ihm das letzte mal schon vorgeschlagen und er hat die
hälfte amazon empfohlen der hat einfach komplette sellout video gemacht unter dem
deckmantel von ich zeige euch die geilen gadgets
wellfield fixes gucken wir jetzt nicht was wir gucken jetzt was passiert wenn die erde aus dem
sonnensystem fliegt 44 minuten world record ist ein bisschen lang aber ich will
wissen was passiert wenn die es wird es wird kalt wahrscheinlich es wird
wahrscheinlich ziemlich ziemlich schnell ziemlich kühl auf der oberfläche
der nacht himmel erscheint uns ruhig und friedlich aber in wahrheit rasen
also so dass der production value wie man so schön sagt es war kurz gesagt
wirklich extrem nice dazu kann ich nur sagen
gerne mit 100.000 stundenkilometern durch die galaxie
alle ihre bahnen exakt vorherzusagen ist nahezu unmöglich zum glück ist das
riesig daher ist es höchst unwahrscheinlich dass wir von irgendwelchen
sterne aus der milchstraße getroffen werden aber ohne dass wir direkt getroffen
werden kann es auf der erde ziemlich ungemütlich werden denn viele solcher
sterne kommen uns schon bedrohlich nahe
um zu verstehen so in den nächsten tagen halo ich werde halo off stream ausprobieren
aspa gefährlich sterne uns werden können müssen bei der wei bei der wei
bevor wir mit dem video richtig anfangen ich habe gerade ein emote gesehen und ich
habe mich gerade gefragt wo ich dieses emote gesehen habe was ist eigentlich
gerade mit stadia gibt es das noch benutzen das noch leute ist das doch
irgendwie in irgendeiner art und weise präsent relevant ich habe ich habe
bestimmt in ja nichts mehr von stadia gehört was ist eigentlich auf stadia
gewonnen stadia was bei geben tut es was noch also
für 20 euro gibt es jetzt als sollte man am anfang vorbestellt für 180
wurde dann eingestellt wurde das glaube ich noch nicht
die haben games gecancelt ja
aber es ist eigentlich so ziemlich das unbedeutendste was es so gibt
alle spiele anzeigen was macht eigentlich moment moment moment was
macht eigentlich magenta gaming jetzt müssen wir mal gucken jetzt jetzt
kommt jetzt jetzt kommen die richtig guten sachen was macht eigentlich
magenta gaming wo wir gerade dabei sind
auch die seite ist gut die seite ist ja mal richtig gut
die ist ja nice die funktioniert auch so gut moment warum so alt war die seite
25 prozent es ist nicht scrollbar und man kann die seite nicht scrollen
die seite ist broken die geht nicht ach deswegen habe ich die auf 25 prozent
gestellt weil die kaputt ist die seite die seite ist komplett kaputt also man
kann die seite nicht bedienen ist dies im arsch sozusagen
vielleicht geht es im firefox ein firefox geht dieser hat jetzt
ernsthaft wirklich hat es die telekom geschafft eine seite zu bauen die im
chrome kaputt ist und im firefox funktioniert adblock filter vielleicht
aber das sollte nicht dazu führen dass eine seite nicht mehr scrollt
wird eigentlich auch kaum was geblockt was ist in instana hier wird noch mehr
geblockt der cookie blocker macht es kaputt
ja magenta gaming ist am start coming soon
ist er hier absolutes absoluter ein highlight jagt das nächste highlight
das ist ja gehört der gar nicht mal auf magenta gaming jawohl was was kostet
der spaß eigentlich gar nichts weil es ist nicht umsonst irgendwie im drinne
wenn man telekom anschließt jetzt buchen und spielen tatsächlich kostet sogar
was was kostet das denn gibt sie weil man weiß
man nicht oder nie nie nicht details
man weiß es nicht
jetzt ein monat kostenlos spiel was kostet es denn magenta gaming preis nicht
dass ich das 695
dafür kriege ich doch schon xbox game pass oder was kostet xbox game pass
weiß wo den xbox game pass alle alle pläne ansehen
ok 99 99 aber mal ganz im ernst wenn ich die auswahl habe sieben euro auszugeben
und den magenta magenta gaming oder den den xbox game pass in den xbox game pass
ok ich weiß dass es nicht wirklich vergleichbar ist das eine ist cloud
gaming das andere nicht aber trotzdem ich sehe den sinn von magenta gaming nicht
so weiß gar nicht wie ich jetzt drauf kommen wir machen es jetzt tun wir gucken
uns jetzt an was passiert wenn die wenn die erde aus dem sonnensystem fliegt
exzellent über schwerkraft sprechen durch die schwerkraft zieht sich im
universum alles an was masse hat so ziehen sich sogar ein millionen lichtjahre
entferntes atom und du gegenseitig an zum glück nimmt diese kraft mit ja und
wisst ihr was das beste ist umso fetter man ist umso mehr zieht man was an
der distanz ab und ist auch von der masse abhängig was nah ist und mehr
masse hat gewinnt eben das kosmische seil ziehen so bestimmen massereiche
objekte wie sich kleinere dinge in ihrer umgebung bewegen mit 99,75 prozent der
gesamten masse in unserem sonnensystem bestimmt die sonne die bewegung und die
umlaufbahnen aller anderen objekte darin vor milliarden jahren kurz nach der
entstehen peng das ist eine berechtigte frage gravitationstechnisch zieht man
natürlich auch medels an aber auf anderer ebene ist das glaube ich dann
eher schwierig der sonne war das sonnensystem leider ist gravitations
anziehung nicht unbedingt das was man braucht chaotisch und gefährlich
und so ist sonne ist einfach nur meber mega pippo fett genau eine teilchen
kollidierten ständig und bildeten die planeten über die eonen ist dann
ordnung eingekehrt heute kreisen die meisten planeten und
asteroiden auf festen umlaufbahnen wir haben die inneren und äußeren
planeten den asteroiden und den körpergürtel und ganz am rand die ortsche
wolke in die eine menge kometen kreisen quasi ein kometen lager diese ordnung
sollte besser nicht gestört werden käme uns ein anderer stern zu nahe würde der
mit seiner schwerkraft alles im sonnensystem an sich reißen und damit
die planeten asteroiden und kometen ins chaos stürzen und das ist keine
theoretische gefahr vor etwa 70.000 jahren flug ein doppelstern aus einem
roten und einem braunen zwerg durch die ortsche wolke und sorgte für
entsprechendes chaos möglicherweise ist seither sogar vor 70.000 was wirklich
ist das erscheint jetzt so kurz und sorgte für entsprechendes chaos möglicherweise ist seither sogar ein
todbringender sturm von asteroiden auf dem weg zu uns bis diese gesagte also
dinger passieren das ist das ist ja quasi gestern gewesen so dinger dachte ich
passieren so irgendwie vor was weiß ich eineinhalb milliarden jahren oder so aus
der ortsche wolke aber das innere sonnensystem erreichen könnte es zwei
millionen jahre dauern aber es gibt noch ein viel größeres problem
gliese 710 ein roter zwerg mit etwa der halben sonnenmasse ist aktuell unterwegs
zu unserem sonnensystem in etwa eine halben millionen jahren was mich auch
immer triggert wenn die amis amis ami aussprache wobei ich muss jetzt nicht
sagen betai golze wisst ihr wie die amis das
aussprechen den beatle juice das finde ich immer richtig pence champions
wird er durch die ortsche wolke fliegen und zum hellsten stern am himmel werden
wenn etwas unser sonnensystem so streift bringt das über hunderttausende jahre
die umlaufbahnen von millionen objekten in der ortschen wolke durcheinander
haben wir pech geraten unsere planeten dann unter beschuss ähnlich wie jungen
pippenhans ist vorbei von kometen und asteroiden zu sehen
die größe glaube ich glaube da haben andere probleme als uns das anzugucken
auslöschen wie es den dinos damals passiert ist da hilft dann auch kein
konjunkturpaket mehr aber es könnte noch schlimmer kommen die galaxie ist ein
ziemlich krasser ort und sterne kommen sich immer mal wieder sehr nah
es wäre also auch möglich dass ein stern direkt durch das innere
sonnensystem durchfliegen würde das wäre blöd blöd ja dass ein anderer
stern mit der sonne kollidiert ist sehr unwahrscheinlich aber darum geht es uns
auch gar nicht zieht ein stern auch nur in der distanz an uns vorbei die wir zur
sonne haben könnte dass die erde aus dem sonnensystem
schleudern die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das in den nächsten fünf milliarden
jahren passiert wird auf etwa eins zu hunderttausend geschätzt klein das ist
glaube ich immer noch unwahrscheinlicher als dass man an corona stirbt oder an
einer corona impfung stirbt ich weiß nicht was so die ob es da
irgendwelche sachen gibt also man kann sich wahrscheinlich sind die chancen
dass man an einer corona impfung stirbt ungefähr in diesen größenordnung ich
mein eins zu hunderttausend das sind dann null, null null null 1 prozent das erscheint
man ein bisschen bisschen wenig dann wahrscheinlich ja weil es ist auf jeden
fall geht dann ist wahrscheinlich doch tatsächlich wahrscheinlicher aber es
ist unwahrscheinlich also aber auch nicht unmöglich genauso könnten die
einzelgängerplaneten entstanden sein ja lotto lotto ist es ist wahrscheinlich als
lotto spielen ja lotto ist ja irgendwie
1 zu 500 millionen oder irgendwie sowas über die wir auch schon ein video
gemacht haben milliarden davon machen in der
galaxie einfach ihr eigenes ding was also wenn uns das sagen wir mal mit einem
durchschnittlichen roten zwerg passieren würde was würde dann aus der erde
wenn die erde aus dem sonnensystem fliegt gelangt der stern ins
sonnensystem ist am himmel ein kleiner orange farbener punkt zu sehen der
monatelang immer größer und heller wird schließlich ist er auch tagsüber zu
sehen bisher sogar größer und viel ich frage mich was die wisst ihr wisst ihr
warum ich also aus einem grund würde ich das gerne erleben weil ich würde
interessieren was die flat earther dazu sagen scheint als der mond zu hell um
direkt hinzuschauen nachts leuchtet der himmel
gespenstisch rot nach ein paar monaten schrumpft der stern dann wieder und mit
ihm die sonne die wird in den nächsten jahren immer kleiner und ihre wärme und
ihr licht immer schwächer rund um die welt wird der tag zur nacht nun bricht
für die menschheit der ewige winter an die polkappen dehnen sich aus und
pflanzen gehen ein wälder erfrieren und tiere sterben in horden passiert die
erde den mars ist ihre durchschnittliche oberflächentemperatur auf etwa minus
50 grad zelsius gefallen aus dem weltall sieht die erde langsam aus wie ein
eisiger mond die blau grüne oberfläche ein leichen blasse so warm weltweit
bricht die infrastruktur zusammen während die temperaturen sinken und
sinken rücken die menschen in ihren häusern zusammen
heizen mit allem was brennt und fürchten den moment wenn ihnen die
nahrungsmittel ausgehen weil nichts mehr wächst für alles was auf der
oberfläche lebt sind die tage gezählt erreicht die erde den jupiter ist ihre
oberflächentemperatur auf minus 150 grad zelsius gesunken
kälter als der kälteste winter der je in der antarktis gemessen wurde klar dass
mittlerweile so ziemlich alles tot ist ohne sonnenenergie verdunstet kein wasser
also bilden sich keine wolken und der wasserkreislauf steht still
irgendwann reichen die polkappen bis zum äquator und alle mehre sind von einer
dicken eischicht ist das das problem ist wenn also wenn man es an der sache
erstelle ich aus dass das problem ist wenn wenn das einmal komplett zufriert
eis oder generell weiß reflektiert ja gut das sonnenlicht also sprich wenn du
einmal zugefroren bist und wenn die uns dann theoretisch wieder an die
position setzen würden wo wir ursprünglich waren würden wir wahrscheinlich
nie wieder auftauen weil wir einfach zu gute sonnenlicht
reflektieren es wird nie wieder warm bis zum äquator und alle mehre sind von
einer dicken eischicht überzogen je kälter die mehre werden umso mehr wasser
friert unter dem eis ein dadurch steigt der salzgehalt in den tiefen ozeanen an
und vergiftet fast alle tiere die dort bis jetzt noch überlebt haben aber ein
paar extrem viele lebewesen in der nähe thermaler quellen könnten auch das
über kalt heute einige bakterien tief schon spät würden von alle dem gar
nichts mitbekommen da der radioaktive zerfalle elemente im erdkern sie immer
noch warm hält erreicht die erde pluto und den körpergürtel ist die sonne zwar
immer noch der hellste stern am himmel aber nur noch einer unter vielen denn
selbst tagsüber herrscht jetzt dunkelheit die temperatur liegt jetzt
noch knapp 40 grad Celsius über dem absoluten nullpunkt also unter dem
gefrierpunkt der gaze in der atmosphäre jetzt beginnt ein schaurig schönes
schauspiel das leider aber keine mehr zu sehen bekommt die gaze in der
atmosphäre gefrieren zu schnee zuerst der stickstoff dann der sauerstoff nach ein
paar jahren liegt eine eisige zehn meter dicke deckel davon über der ganzen
erdoberfläche und nur noch ein hauch von gas bleibt übrig tot und eingefroren
liegt darunter die flora und fauna begraben beim austritt aus dem
sonnensystem wird die erde schließlich zum einzelgänger planeten einsam und
allein reißt sie durch die finsternis leblose und verlassen aber es ist so
abwegig dass auch zettel immerhin würde die menschheit von dieser katastrophe
nicht überrascht wir würden sie schon tausende jahre im voraus bemerken
aufhalten können wir einen stern zwar nicht wirklich aber wir könnten uns
darauf vorbereiten die meisten würden sterben aber ein paar
millionen menschen könnten überleben in riesigen künstlichen habitaten
versorgt durch erdwärme und atomkraft vielleicht sogar fusionsenergie falls
wir es hinkriegen das eis dafür zu nutzen so könnte die menschheit
hunderttausende jahre überleben irgendwann hätten wir uns an die neuen
umstände gewöhnt da habe ich so meinen zweifel dass das funktioniert unsere
nachfahren dokus schauen über eine zeit in der wir um einen eigenen stern
kreisten und auf der erdoberfläche herumspazieren konnten und irgendwann
beschließen wir dann vielleicht ein neues zuhause zu suchen mit etwas glück
fliegt die erde an einem anderen stern mit einem bewohnbaren planeten vorbei
und wir könnten einen neuer anfangen versuchen ohne die ganze atmosphäre im
weg wäre die raumfahrt auch plötzlich sehr viel einfacher
es ist also denkbar dass die letzten überlebenden die erde verlassen und einen
neuen planeten besiedeln der um eine neue sonne kreist eines tages
tausende jahre später erzählen die nachfahren der menschheit vielleicht
legenden über die ferne vergangenheit der erde
geschichten von einem verlorenen zuhause von einem geheimnisvollen
eisplaneten der einsam und allein durch die ewige finsternis des alsts sieht
alles klar
jetzt wissen wir jetzt wissen wir bescheid für den fall der fälle ja da
wissen wir schon mal was auf uns zukommt
ok leute ich gehe jetzt was essen ich habe hunger dann bin ich schon am start
1 2 5 40 ich gehe futtern wir sehen uns bis denn macht es gut
vielleicht nachher noch ein paar roten battlefield mal gucken
boomer hunger genau bis denn macht's gut zu